Das war's für heute.
Der war's für heute.
Das war es für heute für heute.
Das war es für heute für heute für heute für heute.
Das war es für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute.
Das war es für heute für heute für heute.
Das war es für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute für heute.
Das hier noch mal!
Und hier wieder noch 1 Runde!
Das war's für heute.
So, genug Krakonat. Auf geht's.
Ja, hab ich.
Sriiixionz, was auch immer, wie man das genau ausspricht. Hab ich.
Wir haben sogar das Video angeguckt letztens im Stream.
Das war die Inspiration auch dafür.
Was ist mit AliExpress los?
Warum schlägt mir AliExpress Pornhub Hoodie vor?
Ich muss mal auf meinem zweiten Bildschirm kurz gucken, was da passiert, wenn man das jetzt eingibt.
Ich will das jetzt nicht unbedingt hier im Stream angucken, weil man weiß ja nie.
Okay, also zwar mehr.
Also mein Ziel ist, dass ich, sag mal mal so bis März oder so, hoffe ich mal.
Wobei jetzt ein bisschen März, April.
Vielleicht schaffe ich dann wieder unter 100 Kilo.
Tatsächlich? Warum?
Warum gibt's das auf AliExpress?
Warum?
Warum kann ich auf AliExpress Pornhub Hoodie kaufen?
Und warum?
Und warum sieht das auch noch aus wie das Originale?
Ich meine, das ist wahrscheinlich aus der Nähfabrik in Bangladesch entstanden oder so.
Wie übrigens alles andere auch.
Ist interessant, sowas was die nicht alles haben.
Bestimmt offiziell.
Absolut offiziell.
Bessere Frage, warum sollte man das nicht können?
Na, weil ich gedacht habe, dass Pornhub einen eigenen Merchandise Store hat.
Und ich vermute mal, dass es kein offizielles Pornhub Hoodie ist.
Moonbeard das von Twitch Prime. Huge, big brain. Dankeschön. Nice.
So, ich werde jetzt mal kurz erzählen.
Weiß auf weiß war nicht die beste Idee hier zum Vergrößern.
Ich werde jetzt mal kurz erzählen, was ich mir gedacht habe, wie wir das machen.
Und dann gucken wir mal, ob das Ganze funktioniert.
Ich werde jetzt mal ein Notizprogramm aufmachen, ein bisschen was aufkriegen, habe ich mir.
Kikuna. Interessiert in China niemand. Das ist richtig, das juckt die überhaupt nicht.
Ich habe eben noch eine Frage im Chat und zwar.
Zwei Jahre Fachinformatiker für Systemintegration Ausbildung.
Die geht länger als zwei Jahre.
Oder 3,5 Jahre Studierende. Wie relevant ist Praxiserfahrung beim Bewerben?
Ja, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Ich meine, Praxiserfahrung sieht natürlich jeder gerne.
Das kann man pauschal nicht sagen.
Ich meine, es gibt Bereiche, da wird das nicht nur gerne gesehen,
sondern die wollen auch zumindest, wenn das jemand ist, der frisch einsteigt, dass das jemand ist, der studiert hat.
Es ist wirklich, das kann man so pauschal nicht sagen.
Aber du bist auf jeden Fall, wenn du studiert hast, nicht schlechter dran, als wie wir jemand in der Ausbildung gemacht haben.
Eher besser.
Ich meine, du musst natürlich danach gewisse Praxiserfahrungen sammeln,
aber bei den meisten Betrieben ist es jetzt auch nicht so, dass man jetzt der absolute Pro ist, rein durch die Ausbildung.
Man ist ziemlich gut in einem bestimmten Bereich.
Meistens eher dann, wenn man sich auch privat dafür interessiert.
Kannst du einen WLAN-Controller für RGB empfehlen?
Ups, Moment.
Nimm einfach.
Also ich habe letztens zu Weihnachten, habe ich mir ein WS1, eine Lichterkette gekauft,
die 5 Volt Variante, und eine Lichterkette, die hier habe ich mir gekauft.
Die kostet auch nicht viel, 11 Euro.
Seht ihr mal Leute, an Weihnachten waren die teurer.
An Weihnachten haben die noch 20 Euro gekostet.
Und dabei nimmst du einfach, das ist so das einfachste Ding, so einen da.
Und dann brauchst du nur noch einen Netzteil und das war's.
Mehr brauchst du nicht. 5 Volt Netzteil, 5 Volt LED-Leiste und einen ESP32.
Du könntest es auf zwei Jahre verkürzen.
Ja gut.
Ja, aber trotzdem.
Also es gibt einige, die haben eine Ausbildung gemacht, bevor sie studieren gehen.
Wenn du jetzt studieren kannst, es kommt echt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Aber wie gesagt, du studierst nicht umsonst.
Du stehst halt eigentlich schlechter da oder so.
Das ist halt die Frage, ob du Kohle brauchst.
Du könntest so ein Studium, ich kann zum Studium sicherlich nicht viel sagen.
Das Einzige ist Hörensagen.
Ich habe ja nicht studiert.
Wenn ich studiert hätte, könnte ich dir jetzt großartig was erzählen.
Das habe ich ja nicht.
Ich meine, ich kenne ein paar Leute, die studiert haben, aber das bringt ja im Prinzip auch nichts,
wenn ich sage, ja, ich habe gehört, das, bla, bla, bla.
So, also ich habe mir diese Waage hier gekauft.
Ich spoiler jetzt auch noch nicht.
Ich stelle mich jetzt nicht drauf, ich stelle mich erst, ich muss auch eh noch Batterien reinmachen.
Also die Waage habe ich mir gekauft hier, Body Composition Scale 2.
Das Ding gibt es auch bei AliExpress, es ist nochmal eine ganze Ecke billiger.
Und wenn man ein bisschen rumsucht, wie gesagt, aktuell kriegt man das aber relativ günstig.
Hier anscheinend bei Real.
Sogar nicht, dass Real das auch hat.
Also 27 Euro ist relativ günstig und sonst kostet die eher so 35 oder halt in China.
In China kriegst du es halt für, Moment, eben haben wir es doch schon gesehen.
In China kriegst du es halt für 19 Euro oder sowas.
Ah nee, hier 21, 21 Euro.
Mit, oh, nein kriegst du nicht, the fuck, fail.
Me Scale 2 heißt dieses Ding.
Also das ist tatsächlich bei Ship from Spain and Russia.
Das ist relativ günstig bei Real aktuell.
Bei Real ist Versand aus China? Ernsthaft?
Sowas machen die?
WTF?
Ich dachte, das ist sowas wie Saturn.
Das ist viel Zweierchamp, ja, aber echt.
Hier für die ganzen Fußfetischisten.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass die mittlerweile, dass das ein Marketplace ist.
Ich dachte, das ist so ein Supermarkt.
Ich dachte, das ist ein stinknormaler Supermarkt.
Und die haben das halt gerade günstig im Angebot. WTF?
But why?
Naja, dann Aliexpress oder Amazon.
Das sieht nicht aus wie echte Füße.
Das sind Photoshop oder Puppenfüße.
Ich glaube eher, das sind Photoshop.
Das sind Photoshop Füße, Leute.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das ist nie im Leben ein echter Fuß.
Das ist ein Photoshop oder 3D Model Fuß.
Die Musik kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden.
Die Musik kann sich wieder nicht entscheiden, wie laut sie wird.
Also die Mischung von diesem Stream ist wirklich schlecht.
Ich würde sagen, es suckt.
Relaxing Chess.
Okay, das geht ja noch irgendwie.
Also, auf geht's.
Also, was wir machen, ist...
Wie gesagt, ich habe mir diese...
Ich muss erst mal gucken, wie fange ich das denn besser an?
Ich habe mir die Waage bestellt und die ist heute angekommen.
Ich habe sie ja im Stream schon angekündigt.
Wir probieren das jetzt aus.
Und zwar habe ich mir folgendermaßen gedacht, wir machen erst mal die VM an.
VM brauchen wir eh.
Wir machen das unter Linux, weil unter Windows kannst du das eh knicken.
Richtig NA Desktop.
Richtiger NA Desktop hier Windows.
Was promises1 fragt, ich habe dir mal als Passwortmanager Bitworn angeschaut.
Ja, habe ich auch...
Ah, nee.
Du hast dir mal...
Ach so, ich habe es irgendwie falsch gelesen.
Kann man selbst hosten.
Problem ist, ich habe momentan einen Apache Web Server am Laufen.
Bitworn kommt aber als Docker mit.
Das ist übrigens auch der Nachteil.
NiceX, perfekt.
Wenn ich mal wieder Videos mache, kann ich das gut gebrauchen.
Ich kann es wirklich gut gebrauchen, wenn ich Videos mache.
Also, das ist auch so das Problem, was ich mit Bitworn habe, warum ich immer noch bei
KeePass am Start bin.
KeePass ist halt genau das Gegenteil.
KeePass musst du halt in ein File sünden und das ist halt einfach offline.
Es gibt keinen Server oder so.
Es ist halt immer offline.
Bitworn ist halt der Vorteil, du kannst halt theoretisch auf einem Server betreiben und
das halt remote benutzen.
Bei KeePass musst du das immer sünden.
So, und es ist die Frage, wie deine Architektur aussieht.
Also, wenn du das intern hosten möchtest bei dir und von außen drauf zugreifen willst,
dann gibt es mehrere Varianten, aber du wirst wahrscheinlich nicht um eine Portweiterleitung
herumkommen.
Und dann ist die Frage, willst du die Portweiterleitung direkt auf diesen Service machen?
Also, traust du dem soweit?
Oder du stellst einen Nginx oder sowas davor?
Ja, oder einen Apache oder einen Caddy oder einen Traffic oder irgendwas.
Irgendwas reverse proxy-mäßiges.
Ja, aber du musst auf jeden Fall am Eingang eine Portweiterleitung machen, sonst wird das
nicht funktionieren.
Oder du hostest das Ganze im Internet.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das ist für mich persönlich auch der große Nachteil, warum ich immer noch
nicht angefangen habe, mit etwas anderes anzugucken wie KeePass.
Einfach so.
KeePass ist halt, es ist absolut oldschool.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal dieses Benutzer-Interface an.
Das sieht im Prinzip aus wie, so sieht das immer noch aus, das sieht im Prinzip aus
wie wie 2000.
Aber, erstens verwende ich schon eine Weile und zweitens, das einzige was man machen muss,
zu verwenden, ist halt irgendwie sein verschlüsseltes Passwort-File zu SYNKen.
Das heißt, ich muss mich selbst um den SYNK kümmern.
Was wiederum heißt, es ist auch nicht einfach so öffentlich im Internet verfügbar.
Das kann ich beispielsweise so machen, dass wenn ich mit meinem Gerät im WLAN bin daheim,
dass ich dann SYNKE, dass ich muss dann überhaupt nichts irgendwie von außen zugreifbar machen.
Das ist Vorteil und Nachteil zugleich.
Ja, manchen gefällt quasi dieser Always-Online-Ansatz von Bitwarden besser.
Aber ich finde es gut, dass ich aktiv sagen muss, auf diesem Gerät will ich meine Passwort-Datenbank haben
und nicht irgendwo quasi auf einem Server gehostet.
Deswegen bin ich auch immer noch Parkie-Pass.
Irgendjemand hat gefragt, was ich gerade spiele.
Aktuell gibt es eigentlich nur eine Sache, die ich spiele und zwar das da.
Äh, ja, da.
Beste, kann Diablo einpacken und kann Diablo 4 auch einpacken.
Wie bekommt man den Fisch-ASCII-Art-Bildschirmschoner, ASCII-Iquarium-Suchen einfach?
Gibt es bei den meisten.
Also in Arch Linux ist es in den Paketquellen und ansonsten ist es ein Perl-Programm von irgendwie 50 Zeilen.
Kannste einfach runterladen.
Was hältst du von Synology?
Das ist gut, kann man sich kaufen.
Ist bei deiner Hardware noch ein Unterschied zu merken, ob Linux jetzt in einer VM oder Native läuft?
Kommt darauf an, bei was.
Also beim normalen Benutzen hier, ja, aber auch nur, weil ich täglich vor einer Native-Linux-Kiste sitze, merke ich den Unterschied.
Ähm, bei so einem normalen Betrieb eigentlich nicht.
Wo man das halt extrem merkt, ist beim Videos gucken.
Wenn man hier irgendwie Videos auf YouTube aufmacht, dann ist halt das Problem,
dass in der VM der Video-Decoder von der Grafikkarte nicht funktioniert, weil die VM weiß ja von der Grafikkarte im Host nichts.
Also das ist ein Unterschied.
Das merkt man extrem.
Morgen, wie war dein Start in die Woche?
Ich arbeite montags nicht.
Ich arbeite erst morgens.
Morgen.
Vielleicht.
Vielleicht ja auch demnächst noch weniger.
Brauche ich noch mehr Subs, Leute.
Für weniger Wochenarbeitszeit.
Ähm, was meinst du mit Offline-Marks? Jedes Mal die Passwort-Datei schicken?
Genau, wie du die Passwort-Datei schickst, ist ja egal.
Kannst du über Dropbox machen, wenn du es irgendwie online sync haben willst.
Kannst du über Nextcloud machen, kannst du über any sync-Thing machen oder was auch immer.
Du musst die Datei irgendwie auf deinem Fernseher, bei USB, syncen.
Das ist egal. Du musst die Datei über irgendeinen Mechanismus,
der halt nicht Browser und Online-Server ist, in dem Fall,
irgendwie deinen Passwort-Save auf das Gerät kriegen, wo du es verwenden willst.
Wie syncst du direkt von Windows zum Android?
Äh, ich hab das hier.
Ach nee, kann ich dir... Naja, ich kann es dir zeigen, aber ich hab es hier auf dem...
Ja, ich hab den Nextcloud-Client auf und in dem Verzeichnis,
was ich synke, liegt halt mein Keypass drinnen.
Also jetzt hier nicht, weil das ist der...
Das Streaming-Account, da ist überhaupt nichts eingerichtet, ja.
Da ist das Keypass drinnen.
Und dann kannst du hier einstellen, ähm, stellst...
Da stellst du hier ein, wo hier my database liegt in dem Fall, also wo die Keypass-Datei liegt.
Und dann öffnet er das.
Du musst ein bisschen aufpassen.
Mal angenommen, man käme jetzt auf die blöde Idee
und würde ganz schnell parallel auf dem Smartphone und auf dem Desktop die Datei bearbeiten.
Dann hat er ein bisschen Konflikt, dabei er nicht genau weiß, ja, welche Datei ist jetzt die aktuelle.
Also da ist kein irgendwie DIV-Mechanismus oder so eingebaut.
Aber ganz ehrlich, das Problem ist, das hatte ich noch nie.
Ich mein, noch gar nicht, ja.
Zumal ich die Passwort, den Passwort Safe eigentlich ausschließlich auf meinem Desktop bearbeite
und auf anderen Geräten, wenn ich ihn da überhaupt verwende, dann trag ich da eigentlich nichts ein,
sondern greif da nur drauf zu.
Deswegen ist es für mich nach wie vor immer noch der beste Passwort-Manager.
Und was man auch nicht unterschätzen darf, wenn es um dieses Thema geht, Keypass, das ist, das ist uralt.
Keypass, guck mal auf Wikipedia, wann das Ding rausgekommen ist.
Das ist uralt.
Das ist first release, ähm, hier, erstes Release 2003.
Und bis jetzt gab es keine irgendwie großartigen Skandale, Sicherheitslücken, sondern Probleme um dieses Programm.
Das ist auch eine Sache, die man, gerade wenn es um so Security-Geschichten ist, auch zu schätzen wissen muss.
Es mag neuere Software geben, die mit Sicherheit schöner zu bedienen ist, besser aussieht, vielleicht auch Komfort ein bisschen besser ist.
Aber die hat keine 17 Jahre auf dem Buckel, wo sie funktioniert.
Man weiß, dass sie halbwegs sicher ist.
Also das ist schon nicht verkehrt.
Welches Bild spielst du in POE?
Ich hab zwei, ich hab zwei, ähm, ich hab so einen Praindead-Summoner-Bild, ähm, einfach Spectres raus, Skelette raus, Zombies raus und Bam.
Und ich hab ein reines, reines Rise-Spectre-Bild auch noch.
Aber ich bin da jetzt noch nicht so weit, ich bin noch nicht mal irgendwie 80 plus.
Ich bin jetzt gerade mal durch mit fast, fast, noch nicht mal, fast, mit der Story auf dem zweiten Charakter.
Ich muss jetzt noch diese ganze, ich hab hier ewig nicht gespielt.
Ich muss noch diese ganzen Pantheon-Dinger machen und Labyrinth-Geschichten und sonst was.
Aber, so wie das ist, ich bin natürlich wieder der Theorie-Crafter.
Ich hab natürlich schon Guides angeguckt.
Hey, ich hab mit letzten, was?
Hey, ich habe mir letzten Ubuntu installiert.
Ubuntu, ähm, Ubuntu installiert.
Weißt du, warum die Netplayern nutzen und nicht mehr die Alte?
Weil sie denken, sie sind wahnsinnig schlau.
Ich versteh den, das versteh ich auch nicht.
Ganz ehrlich, Netplan ist so ein Schwachsinn.
Wer das noch nicht gesehen hat, ich zeig euch das mal kurz.
Genau, so macht man jetzt Netzwerk-Config unter Ubuntu.
Es gibt mittlerweile, ich glaub, fünf Varianten, wie man, wie man da Netzwerk-Config machen kann.
Du kannst, ähm, die alte Variante machen, Interfaces.
Du kannst System-D, Network-D machen.
Du kannst Network-Manager machen.
Du kannst Netplan machen.
Und bestimmt noch, ja gut, statisch von Hand konfigurieren kannst du natürlich auch.
Oder WPA-Supplikan für WLAN.
Also im Prinzip, es ist, es ist komplett lächerlich, dass die jetzt mit so einem Scheiß anfangen.
Aber Canonical macht das gerne, oder wie spricht man ja hier aus, Canonical, Canonical, die Ubuntu-Typen.
Die haben den Hang dazu, eigene Dinge zu machen, die sonst keiner verwendet.
Ich weiß nicht, warum sie das machen.
Es ist total bescheuert.
Sie sollen, also ganz ehrlich, ich habe nicht verstanden, was so schlimm an einer Interfaces-Conf ist.
Teinser, das geht nicht.
Also technisch nicht möglich.
Propsrush, also ich muss, muss, muss ich sagen, ich habe ja auch mal eine ganze Weile, 40 Stunden die Woche gearbeitet.
Ähm, mittlerweile kann ich mir das gar nicht mehr vorstellen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie ich das ausgehalten habe.
Das Wochenende ist ja schon vor, quasi vorbei, bevor es angefangen hat.
Das ist der Witz.
Also ich bin eher gerade am Überlegen, ob ich nicht gucken soll, dass ich noch weniger arbeite.
Guck mal, ob ich das nicht mit meinem Chef beibringen kann.
Aber, ähm, mittlerweile bin ich noch nicht ganz sicher, ob ich das mache.
Was wird hier gemacht?
Wir lesen gleich per Bluetooth meine Vaga aus, die ich mir gekauft habe.
Nekro, ja Nekro ist übelst Residenz-Liefer.
Aber das ist das beste, Summoner-Build ist das beste Noob-Build für Passive-Exler, wenn man keinen Plan hat.
Welchen Passport-Manager würdest du Non-Techie-Freunden empfehlen?
Boah, keine Ahnung.
Ich benutze nur KeyPass.
Aber weißt du, ganz ehrlich, KeyPass ist, ist okay, ja.
Du triffst das mal an.
Hier, KeyPass.
Oh, nein.
Das kann doch im Prinzip jeder.
New-Database.
Machen wir hier, keine Ahnung, Desktop.
Master-Passport.
1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Huge Passport.
Ah.
Ah, yes.
Was?
Skip.
Guck mal, der Michael ist auch schon da.
Der war eben noch im Chat und schon ist er in KeyPass.
So, und ich meine, das kann auch jemand verwenden, der nicht gerade sonderlich technisch versiert ist.
Du kannst hier verschiedene Kategorien anlegen.
Das meiste bei mir daheim, ist ehrlich gesagt, also hier, was ich verwende, ist eigentlich alles hier drin, in dieser Kategorie.
Da sagst du einfach, neues Passwort anlegen, und dann sagst du hier, keine Ahnung, GMX oder irgendwie Google oder YouTube, Login, Username, Blob.
So, und dann kannst du hier einen Passwortgenerator da drin, der den Passwort generiert.
Du kannst auch verschiedene, verschiedene Dinger verwenden oder hier auswählen, wie er ein Passwort generieren soll.
Das Passwort hier, und dann kannst du hier noch ein paar Notizen hinschreiben.
Kannst sowas zum Beispiel sagen wie, geheime Antwort ist 03D, geheime Frage, Geburtsort, so irgendwas.
Kannst deine Gebrutzort, kannst dir jede Menge Zeug einrichten, auch für Browser Plugins.
So, speichern, save, fertig. Mehr musst du nicht machen.
Und wenn du das Video öffnest, musst du halt einmal am Start das Masterpasswort eingeben, kannst dir alles angucken.
Das kriegt im Prinzip auch jemand hin, der technisch jetzt nicht so wahnsinnig versiert ist.
Da muss jetzt kein huge brain für haben.
Ich gebe zu, es sieht nicht aus wie eine absolute bleeding edge 2020 Anwendung, aber muss es auch gar nicht.
Ich denke, wie gesagt, der größte Vorteil bei der Geschichte ist, dass die Software von 2003 ist in der ersten Version,
und man seit 17 Jahren sich darauf verlassen kann und nichts Großartiges passiert ist.
Man darf ja auch nicht ausblenden bei der ganzen Geschichte.
Dass man diesem Programm die Login-Daten anvertraut für seinen kompletten Lebensinhalt.
Für alles.
Also da wäre ich vorsichtig.
Und generell, ganz ehrlich Leute, Lastpass.
Ihr solltet niemals, ich kann es nicht verstehen, wie jemand einem Online-Service seinen Lebensinhalt anvertraut.
Das kann ich nicht verstehen.
Das ist mir komplett, absolut unbegreiflich.
Wie man einen Cloud-Service als Passwort-Manager verwenden kann.
Verstehe ich nicht.
So.
Hey.
Wom loss, welche Virtualisierungssoftware nutzt du privat?
Ja, hier vor immer Workstation.
Ich habe sie alle schon mehr oder weniger benutzt, aber auf dem Desktop vor allem unter Windows gefällt mir vor immer Workstation am besten.
Der Blobsrusher sagt, ich speichere meine Passwörter generell nur in der Magenta-Cloud.
Excellent. Advice.
So, so. Macht es auch. So muss man es machen. Nur in die Magenta-Cloud.
Wusstet ihr überhaupt, dass Aldi Cloud-Gaming hat jetzt?
Ja, guck mal. Aldi hat jetzt Cloud-Gaming. Habt ihr das schon gesehen?
Hast du einen Firefox-Endon für Keypass? Ja. Copy-Paste.
Ach ja, und auch noch ein Tipp für euch mal hier. Das ist wirklich nicht schlecht.
Also wer bis jetzt noch keinen Passportmanager hat und auch sagt, eigentlich brauche ich keinen Passportmanager für die paar Passwörter, die ich habe,
oder hauptsächlich brauche ich 99% der Passwörter nur als Login im Browser, dann macht ihr, dann geht ihr in die Settings.
Das kann ich jedem nur empfehlen. Macht das, Leute. Macht das.
Geht in Firefox, geht auf Einstellungen und dann geht hier auf...
Ich glaube, es ist Firefox, genau. So, und dann geht ihr hier hin, wo es Logins und Passworts.
Und dafür gebt ihr den Masterpassport.
Das müsst ihr, dann müsst ihr einmal beim Starten, nee Schwachsinn, gar nicht beim Starten von Firefox,
sondern wenn eine Webseite Login machen möchte und quasi das Login-Formular Auto vervollständigen möchte,
dann müsst ihr einmal euer Masterpassport pro Firefox-Sitzung eingeben.
Also quasi einmal pro Rechnerstart im Endeffekt müsst ihr das eingeben.
Aber macht das hier. Das ist das einfachste und bequemste, was man machen kann, wenn man keinen Passportmanager bewendet.
Das ist lokal. Das ist rein lokal. Das ist nichts...
Ich könnte natürlich, ich könnte Firefox Sync anmachen, aber ich glaube, das Sync dann die...
Das Passwort zeige ich nicht mit.
Das ist rein lokal, solange ihr nicht Firefox Sync anmacht. Das ist rein lokal.
Also wenn ihr, wenn ihr... Und es geht auch nachträglich übrigens.
Das geht auch nachträglich. Also wenn ihr jetzt hier im Firefox schon 50 Einträge für Passwörter drinne habt,
dann macht das nichts. Einfach Masterpassport anmachen, Passwort vergeben
und es wird alles mit dem Masterpassport verschlüsselt. Autovervollständigung funktioniert noch.
Das Einzige, was ihr einmalig machen müsst, ist, also bei jedem Start vom Firefox, beim ersten Mal Login,
müsst ihr einmal das Masterpassport eingeben.
Und selbst wenn ihr ein absolut dummes Passport nehmt, so wie mein Firefox oder 123456,
es ist einfach viel besser und das geht schnell. Ich meine 123456 hat sich mega schnell getippt
oder irgendwie mein Firefox... Es ist nichts tolles dabei.
Und das ist viel, viel besser, als wenn ihr das Zeug auf der Platte legen habt.
Weil überlegt mal, solltet ihr euch wirklich irgendwann mal was einfangen, sei es ein...
Sei es irgendwas, was aus Remote-Zugriff auf euren Rechtern... Irgendwas!
Es ist eben egal was. Ihr seid mit einer verschlüsselten Passwort-Datei einfach schon mal 90% sicherer unterwegs,
also die 0-15-User, wo du dir die Firefox-Config kopierst und du hast Zugriff auf das komplette Leben des jeweiligen Benutzers.
Natürlich gibt es Services mit 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung oder so, ist klar.
Aber, aber auch da, ganz ehrlich, selbst das ist, wenn man den Firefox-Profile-Ordner klaut, kein Ding,
weil bei den meisten Seiten machst du einmalig pro Browser Authentifizierung oder du hast zumindest mal ein paar Tage Ruhe,
wo du 2-Faktor-Authentifizierung machen musst.
Das heißt, wenn jemand euren Firefox-Profile-Ordner kopiert, dann hat er auch eure ganzen Cookies und Sessions und Geschiss.
So, und deswegen macht einfach das Master-Passwort rein in Firefox.
Es ist so gut wie kein Aufwand, es geht nachträglich zu machen und es ist schon mal viel sicherer als ohne.
Also das ist das Mindeste, was ich machen würde.
Ob Google so eine Funktion hat, habe ich keine Ahnung, ehrlich gesagt.
Ok, Chrome macht sowas anscheinend nicht.
Aber selbst wenn, das ist auch gut.
Also macht das, das meine ich jetzt, das kann jeder machen jetzt gleich und er ist einfach sicherer unterwegs.
Ok, auf geht's Leute. Schön lang rumgelabert, 36 Minuten und noch nichts gemacht.
Ok, also, ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal, bevor wir anfangen,
da muss ich ein Stückchen lauter.
Sagen wir mal, dieser komische Track, der ist auch überall drin, oder?
So, also, was wir jetzt machen, ist einmal, wie gesagt, die Waage habe ich hier am Start und dann habe ich noch so einen Controller.
Aber da müssen wir heute nichts Großartiges programmieren.
Da mache ich da, flashe ich eine Firma und dann habe ich noch so einen Controller.
So einen Controller. Aber da müssen wir heute nichts Großartiges programmieren.
Da mache ich da, flashe ich eine Firmware drauf, die per die Bluetooth-Geräte auslesen kann.
So, und zwar habe ich auf GitHub folgendes gefunden.
Das stimmt nicht, ich habe es nicht gefunden.
Ich habe das aus einem Video.
Und zwar, auch einen Channel, den ich empfehlen kann, ist richtig gut.
Wer auf Microcontroller-Zeug und ein bisschen Heimautomatisierung steht, kann ich den Channel hier nur empfehlen.
Ein Schweizer, sagt er auch am Anfang immer.
Und der hat mich auf die Idee gebracht mit der ganzen Geschichte.
Und der macht wirklich sehr gute Videos.
Keine Videos in Form von, ey Leute, guckt mal her, heute zeige ich euch.
Ne, wirklich sehr gut konzentriert die Informationen zusammen in meistens 10 Minuten Video.
Also den Channel kann man wirklich empfehlen.
Genau, da hat mich auf die Idee gebracht, dass ich muss das Ganze mal ausprobieren.
So, Cloud Gaming, Telekom, machen wir mal fort.
Ähm, so.
Flo96.
Ne, wollte ich gar nicht einplatten, wo habe ich es denn?
Wirechamp.
Ne, heute verwenden wir kein ESP 6, äh, 6, äh, ne.
82, 66.
Sondern, ähm, ESP 32.
Okay, ähm.
Das heißt, als erstes brauche ich, muss ich mir mal die Firmware runterladen hier.
GitHub repo klonen.
Machen wir mal mkdir, äh, vage, ne, mkdir kona.
So, klonen wir uns das ganze repo.
Und dann müssen wir mal auf die Seite gucken, wie das funktioniert.
Weil anscheinend ist das etwas experimental feature.
Aber ist auf dem ESP 32 nicht der ESP 86, 86, 66? Nö.
Das sind zwei komplett unterschiedliche Chips.
Der ESP 32 ist ein Dual-Core mit 240 MHz und der ESP 86, 86 ist auf jeden Fall ein Single-Core mit weniger.
So, ähm, also blablabla, Devices, ja, immer Board, brauche ich nicht.
Ich will eigentlich gucken, wie man das ganze upload.
Upload. So, wir müssen das ganze hochladen.
Wir öffnen das jetzt einfach, wir gucken mal da rein.
So.
Also.
Visual Studio Code aufmachen.
Auf den zweiten Desktop. Ups.
Ich habe gerade mein Terminal verschoben.
What?
What the hell?
Okay, irgendwie hat es gerade etwas rumgespackt, meine Tastatur.
Ich weiß nicht, was er für Schmerzen hat.
Okay, ähm, so, und was schreibt der jetzt hier?
Man soll hier das einkommentieren, was man brauchen, machen wollen.
So, und zwar wir wollen, das habe ich mir im Vorfeld schon mal angeschaut, wir wollen natürlich das da.
Wir haben einen ESP32 und wir wollen das ganze über Bluetooth machen.
Was programmiert der gute Mann? Äh, ich programmiere heute wahrscheinlich gar nichts Großartiges.
Ich habe gerade dieses Projekt Git cloned und wir bilden das jetzt und uploaden das auf einen ESP32.
Damit ich per Bluetooth meine Waage auslesen kann.
Open MQTT Gateway, ja.
Q-Chat?
So, also ESP32. Okay, bilden wir das Ganze mal und gucken, ob das funktioniert.
Äh, oh, failed. Warum?
Äh.
Ah, jetzt, jetzt funktioniert es.
Einfach noch mal kompilieren, schon funktioniert es.
So.
Machen wir den ganzen Kram hier zu.
Okay, das Ganze ist kompiliert, sehr schön.
Soweit ich das gesehen habe, funktioniert es folgendermaßen zu konfigurieren.
Diesmal haben wir nicht das Problem, dass ich wieder mein WLAN Passwort leake.
Sondern ich kann das über das Handy nebenbei konfigurieren, über so ein Portal.
Ja, heute ist Gewicht League, genau, heute ist Gewicht League.
Das heißt, was ich jetzt machen werde, ich nehme erstmal einen ESP32 und, äh, habe ich den hingeschmissen, hier.
ESP, das ist, wie gesagt, so ein ganz NodeMCU ESP32, so ein Ding ist das, so ein DevBoard.
Der da, von Tyler habe ich hier liegen.
Habe ich mir auch mal irgendwie im 20er Pack AliExpress bestellt, kostet nichts.
Also wenn ich sage, kostet nichts, bezieht sich das meistens, also bei mir ist nichts.
Sagen wir mal so, wenn sich das im Bereich von einem Euro bis fünf Euro bewegt, dann sage ich immer im Stream so, kostet nichts.
Ja, natürlich kostet das was, umsonst ist das alles nicht, aber es ist nicht teuer.
Ähm, und man kann sich auf AliExpress, kann man sich ESP32 Boards, die sind ein bisschen teuer als ESP866,
aber, ähm, die können auch mehr, kann man sich ESP32 Boards wirklich für einen Apple und Nike kaufen.
Hier, guckt es euch mal an, da ist so ein Teil, 3,47 Euro, da kannst du dich echt nicht beschweren.
Hier, kostet nichts. Lieferzeit noch viel, die Lieferzeit, oh Gott, AliExpress hat mich mal wieder IP-locked oder was auch immer.
Äh, AliExpress gibt es, ähm, es kommt drauf an, also was man bei AliExpress machen kann, was ganz sinnvoll ist,
man geht auf, hier, ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen, weil mich das Ding irgendwie ausgesperrt hat, habe ich es hier noch irgendwie auf, genau.
Man kann hier unten das Land auswählen, das ist oftmals ganz gut.
Ähm, allerdings ist manchmal das Problem, dass die sagen, hey, Spanien und Russland liefert nicht nach Germany,
aber manchmal kann man da auch Frankreich auswählen oder, ähm, äh, was haben sie noch ganz gerne, Frankreich und England?
Beispielsweise kann man dann auch nochmal gucken, ob es auf Banggood was gibt, übrigens, beste Seite der Name ever, ja, Banggood.
Da können wir auch nochmal MeScale suchen, vielleicht haben die da auch eine.
Ja, hier MeScale-Wage, Assas-Teil, oh, äh, Language, Hallo, what the fuck, Country, Germany, Deutschland.
So, und da kann man dann auch gucken, wo die hinliefern und, ähm, im Prinzip macht es keinen Unterschied, ja, also, das ist die gleiche, ist die gleiche Waage.
Und hier sieht man zum Beispiel, hier hat man schon die Auswahl, ob aus, was ist das, Tschechien oder so, CZ, oder aus China.
Und, ähm, hier ist es auch, Bearbeitungszeit versandt in 24 Stunden, hier ist das Ganze auch schneller, ja.
Also, man muss ein bisschen, man muss ein bisschen rumgucken, man muss, wenn man China bestellt oder Indien, ich glaube, Banggood ist Indien,
also sprich, wenn man da bestellt, man muss da nicht zwangsläufig 1-2 Monate auf sein Zeug warten.
Man muss einfach nochmal mit ein bisschen mit Brain gucken, wo es gerade die Sachen gut gibt.
Und vor allem bei Banggood kann ich empfehlen, dass man das halt filtert, ähm, auch nach Land.
So, und wenn wir jetzt hier sagen, kostenlos, wir haben sogar kostenloser Versand, also sprich, das Ding kostet 25 Dollar und ist wahrscheinlich, äh,
übermorgen, ist bis Ende der Woche da.
Ähm, man kann jetzt, wo kommt man die Währung nochmal umstellen?
Weil da muss man auch mal schauen, manche Seiten gebaten, also manche Seiten sind hardcore am gebaten,
die rechnen nicht mit den aktuellen Kursen um.
Und manche rechnen mit sehr merkwürdigen Kursen um, das heißt, oftmals ist es besser, man stellt die,
wo kommt man nochmal die, die Währung umstellen?
Currency?
Hm, ach, hier oben.
Also gucken wir mal, es kostet, äh, hier 25,99.
So, dann stellen wir das mal ein Euro um.
So, 28 Dings, das machen wir hier, 2 Euro aktueller Preis, 23,33, ne?
Also man kann manchmal ein bissl, ein bissl was sparen, ähm, je nach, je nach Währung, in der man das bestellt.
Aber es ist, eigentlich macht es keinen großen Unterschied.
Okay.
Genau, so ein Ding habe ich hier liegen, das schließe ich jetzt mal an.
Äh, wo habe ich denn jetzt hingeschmissen? Hier, das schließe ich jetzt mal an.
Und dann flashen, dann uploaden wir das Ganze da drauf.
Auf, komm her. USB-Anschlüsse macht man prinzipiell immer, immer falsch rum rein.
Da ist er.
Achtung, hier sollte er jetzt angezeigt werden.
Äh, ja, da.
Also, ist erkannt, jetzt können wir das Ding uploaden.
So, der schreibt jetzt die Firma auf den Microcontroller drauf.
Und danach kann ich, ähm, auf meinem Handy einrichten.
In welches WLAN er soll. Das ist nämlich ganz gut, weil dann habe ich nicht wieder das Problem, dass ich ausfüße, dass ich mein WLAN-Passwort leake oder sowas.
Was mache ich denn hier über dieses komische Ding?
Okay.
So, also wenn das Ding startet, sollte ich jetzt eigentlich einen Portal kriegen, wo ich mein Zeug eingeben kann. Schauen wir mal.
Oder auch nicht.
Ich kriege keinen Portal, wo ich mein Zeug eingeben kann.
Warum nicht?
Hab ich das vergessen?
Okay, Moment. Mal mal seriellen Output anschalten.
But why? Warum geht das nicht?
Ich resette den Controller mal.
Oh. Oh, der USB-Anschluss ist ein bisschen wackelig.
Ja, ist ja gut. Ist ja gut. Keine Panik jetzt.
Der USB-Anschluss ist ein bisschen wackelig.
Uploaden wir das Ganze nochmal.
Ich habe es mal ein bisschen verkackt. Ich bin auf den USB-Anschluss draufgedreht.
Und jetzt hängt der USB-Anschluss hier so schräg.
Ich habe den wieder festgelötet, aber nachdem ich es nicht ganz gerade festgelötet habe, ist hier neben ein bisschen da.
Das hier ein bisschen höher als das unten.
Das heißt, der USB-Anschluss wackelt jetzt ein bisschen. Ah ja, hier. Okay, wow.
Ah, nice.
Warum? Das ergibt überhaupt keinen Sinn.
Warum ist das jetzt noch konfiguriert von meinem Test vorhin?
Wenn ich es gerade frisch hochgeladen habe, bin ich jetzt total verwirrt.
Using Passwort Omega-Lol, ja.
Weiß, using Passwort Omega-Lol.
Die wird nicht überschrieben.
But why? Warum nicht?
Das muss überschrieben werden. Ich habe es neu geflasht.
Das Geile ist, jetzt muss ich mein WLAN-Passwort ändern.
Das ist eh nur mein IoT-China-WLAN-Passwort. Da kommt man eh nirgendwo hin.
Ach Gott, ey. Ändere ich halt mein WLAN-Passwort mal wieder.
Man hat ja sonst nichts zu tun, ne?
Also WLAN-Passwort ändern.
Weil die da schreiben auf ihrer Seite, die sagen, um Wi-Fi zu resetten, soll man neu flaschen.
Tja.
Okay. Jetzt muss ich erstmal mein WLAN-Passwort ändern. Jetzt machen wir Omega-Lol 2.
Oh.
Save. Ah, yes.
Jetzt müssen wir kurz warten, bis das WLAN-Passwort geändert ist. Sehr gut.
Tja, wie resette ich denn jetzt das Passwort von dem Ding?
Ja, Flow 96, der USB-Anschluss reißt gerne mal ab.
Ja, also so sollte das dann aussehen, wenn das Ganze funktioniert.
Das Passwort ist jetzt halt nicht mehr Omega-Lol.
Wie resette man das denn? Ah, man muss das einfach nochmal drücken. Verstehe. Ah, yes.
Dann machen wir den Monitor wieder aus. Es ist ja wenigstens gut, dass das da steht, ja.
Hä, musst du jetzt nicht alle Passworte in anderen Geräten ändern? Nö.
Ich habe einen extra WLAN angelegt, nur für Streaming und nur zum Testen.
Genau. Ja. Aber trotzdem ist es doof, weil ich will ja das weiterverwenden können.
Ah, jetzt hat er. Jetzt hat er es. Okay. Jetzt kann ich mich verbinden mit.
Jetzt geht das Ganze. Okay, sehr schön. Ah, yes. Jetzt kann ich mich verbinden mit dem Handy.
Und dann kann ich WLAN-WLAN-Gedünge eingeben. Also, ich mache jetzt das da im Prinzip, was hier steht.
Also, ich sage jetzt hier WLAN konfigurieren.
Passwort, das lese ich jetzt nicht vor und es ist nicht mehr Omega-Lull irgendwas, sondern es fängt mit 9 an. Soviel kann ich verraten.
Okay. Server, alles eingetragen, passt, save.
Gut, jetzt habe ich den ganzen Krams hier eingetragen und jetzt können wir mal gucken mit folgendem.
Ich habe mir das Ganze schon mal copy und paste-fähig gemacht.
Also, ich habe einen MQTT-Server laufen auf meinem Raspberry und zwar hier unter, auf dem da.
Das heißt, ich muss jetzt machen Mosquito-Sub. Damit kann man sich die Message-Q angucken.
Genau. MQTT. So, den muss ich jetzt quasi, den muss ich jetzt sagen, der Server, wo ich hin will.
Dann muss ich ihm sagen, der Port 1388, 1883 und dann das Topic.
Das Topic ist das, was man hier hinstellt. Das ist quasi der Name von der, ja, von dem, von dem, wie nennt man das?
Von dem Topic halt. Worauf man die Sachen publisht.
So, Home. Da muss man mal eine Router hinten machen, dass er alles unterhalb anzeigt.
So, wir wollen wirklich alles anzeigen und wir creppen jetzt, wir creppen jetzt mal, wir creppen jetzt mal nach, was creppen wir mal?
Also, ich mache jetzt erstmal meinen Mac-Adressen-Filter hinten dran. Sicher, sicher. Mal ein bisschen Mac-Adressen-Filter.
Ich muss ja nicht, ich muss ja nicht die komplette Nachbarschaft hier revealen.
Ok, das Ding ist anscheinend online, wie es aussieht. Ja, das Desk können wir zumachen.
Ich drücke jetzt mal Reset. Das heißt, da sollte er sich wieder online melden.
So, Reset gedrückt. Reset ist raus. Ah, da ist er. Ok, sehr gut.
Zumindest sollte er jetzt eigentlich Geräte finden.
Das ist die Xiaomi-Waage. Er sollte jetzt eigentlich Geräte finden.
Bei Bluetooth macht er aber nicht. Ok, ähm...
Was braucht der ESP32 im Deep Sleep? Kommt auf das Board an.
Der ESP32 selbst verbraucht ein paar Mikroamper, aber das Board, je nachdem, was da drauf ist und wie intelligent das Design ist, braucht deutlich mehr.
Ah ja, hier, guck mal. Guck mal, wie huge mein Set funktioniert zum Mac-Adressen-Filtern.
Ok. Ah, passt so. Hier ist mein Shield-TV. Hier ist mein Backlight vom Fernsehen.
Das Ding ist übrigens richtig geil. Weiß nicht, ob ich das hier schon mal gezeigt habe im Stream.
Das ist so Ambilight für Fernseh, die kein Ambilight haben.
Hier. Das ist richtig geil. Also das wirklich mal eine Investition gewesen, die sich gelohnt hat.
Ähm, ja, so sieht das ungefähr aus dann drüben.
Wir haben ja auch die optimalen Voraussetzungen, weil drüben im Wohnzimmer ist hinter dem Fernsehen einfach nur eine weiße Tapete.
Also das hat sich wirklich gelohnt. Ok, so. Clear. Und das heißt, wir crepten jetzt nach...
Crept. Wait.
So, und jetzt mache ich die Wache an und stelle mich auf die Wage drauf und wir gucken, ob der was findet.
Ich mache ja die Wage. So, jetzt ist Kokona-Time, Leute. Kokona.
Huge Kokona-Time.
Ok. Also. Warte mal.
Ach so. Maximal 150 kg oder nach geht sie kaputt steht drauf.
Was hast du? Sein Wagen. Hast du mal Batterie? Feuchte.
Es dreht sich. Weiß ich genau warum.
Ah, jetzt. Ok.
Warte, dass das funktioniert.
Jetzt stelle ich mich mal auf die Wache.
So wirklich machen tut er nicht, oder? Und kommt fast ohne Crep.
Probieren wir mal aus. Hier. Da ist es doch. Hat doch funktioniert.
Hat doch funktioniert. Hat doch funktioniert.
Also hat sich letzte Woche kein Mittagessen schon gelohnt, ist wieder ein Kilo weniger.
104 mit einem Bein. Na klar, 104 mit einem Bein. Nein, ich habe mich komplett draufgestellt, weil das Ding das möchte,
was aber lustig ist, dass da kein Baum, warum funktioniert das mit dem Crep nicht?
Ok, ich stelle mich nochmal drauf. Gucken wir nochmal. Gewicht liegt.
Hat es rumgespacht? Warum?
Wollen wir jetzt mal ausprobieren, ob die Körperfett Anzeige auch funktioniert?
Allerdings, um das auszuprobieren, ob die Körperfett Anzeige funktioniert, muss ich die Socken ausziehen, weil mit Socken an funktioniert das Ganze nicht.
Wollen wir Körperfett auch nochmal ausprobieren? Aber vorher muss ich mal was anderes gucken.
Leute, ich habe abgenommen. Spontaner Gewichtsverlust.
Ich muss aber mal kurz vorher was schauen. Ich muss mal schnell ausmachen und was schauen.
Ja, sehr gut. Hat funktioniert, so wie es soll. Jetzt müsst ihr mir das mal sehen.
Ich muss mal kurz in meinem Router gucken, was das Ding jetzt für eine IP gekriegt hat.
Warte mal, welche IP hat das Ding jetzt gekriegt?
Da ist er.
Ich ziehe mal meine Socken aus und gucke mal, was da bei Körperfett rauskommt.
Wo ist Kev?
Wollt ihr jetzt anzeigen 104,7?
Haufen bitte. Weil, da ist es doch hier. 104,6.
Ganz schön schwere Socken, oder?
Und jetzt müsste man wissen, wie man Widerstand zu Gewicht, wie man da den Körperfettanteil mit ausrechnet.
Ich habe keine Ahnung. Weiß das jemand, wie das geht?
1,5B denke ich, ja genau.
Ja, ich muss erstmal Socken anziehen, sonst wäre die Füße zu kalt.
Und jetzt rechts oder links?
Kann das sein, dass ich die ganze Zeit einen Socken links rum und den anderen rechts rum hatte?
Big Brain Bekleidung. Okay, wie funktioniert denn das?
Ist da ein Calculator?
Fat Body Calculator, easy. Ne, so nicht.
Wie kann man mit einem Online Calculator rechnen, ob man schwanger ist?
Achso. Ne, das ist nicht der Calculator, den ich brauche.
Ne, ich habe meine Größe, ich habe mein Gewicht und ich habe mein, ja, welche Einheit ist denn das?
Das ist Widerstand, Widerstand müsste oben sein, allerdings, ich weiß nicht, 424 oben ist nicht so viel, oder?
Na gut, ich meine, Körper ist ja im Prinzip fast nur Wasser.
Also ich brauche jetzt irgendeine Formel, wie ich das ausrechnen kann.
Auf Deutsch, wie funktioniert das? Bioelektrische Impendanzanalyse. Ah, yes, alles klar.
Zylindrisches Modell. Ah, das bin ich. Jetzt erkenne ich es auch endlich.
Und ja, wie berechnet man das jetzt hier?
Natürlich alles Muskelmasse, aber ich habe keine Ahnung.
Das ist sicher irgendein Count, ja.
Das ist Big Brain, Quick Quick Muffs, ja.
Leute, ich weiß nicht, wie das funktioniert.
Also, okay, wir haben es jetzt raus, ich habe es geleakt, 104,6 und 424, was auch immer, wie viel oben Widerstand, von Fuß zum Fuß.
Ob jetzt mal mit Formel, okay, okay.
What the fuck?
What?
Ich habe legit keinen Plastenschimmer, wirklich nicht, keinen Plastenschimmer, wie man das berechnet.
MLG legit, keine Ahnung.
Was ist da?
Oh, der Chat ist Massive Brain, ja.
Der Chat ist Big Brain.
Also, die Lukaski und Bollon-Schucks-Formel.
Also, okay, das machen wir jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt, pass mal auf, wir machen das mit dem Windows Calculator.
Okay, also, okay, das geht von rechts nach links, das passt.
Also, es, Höhe in Zentimeter, also 175, hoch 2, durch, was war das?
402, äh, 400, nee, nee, 424, so, äh, okay, plus.
Also, im Prinzip ist das hier mal eins, oder?
Also sprich, das hier fällt weg, wenn ich eine Frau bin, sehe ich das richtig?
Okay, also plus 3,05, plus.
Nee, Leute, wir machen das, wir machen das anders.
Wir rechnen das einfach aus, also, ähm, geh mal fort, wie klärt man den Scheiß hier?
Windows, geh weg, löschen, CE.
Also, wir machen das von innen nach außen, also, wir rechnen jetzt 175, hoch 2, durch 424.
Okay, das da, so, okay, wir, wir runden das mal auf, ähm, so, plus.
Also, im Prinzip ist das hier, machen wir, klammern wir anders.
So, sagt mir hier, wenn mein QuickMuffs nicht stimmt, was ich hier mache, so, ne?
Ähm, okay, also, das da, also, 26, irgendwas, okay.
So, das fällt weg, mal eins, das bleibt einfach so.
Äh, Gewicht in Kilo, also, machen wir, links, mal, äh, was ist das, kommen wir 104, 105, ist jetzt egal.
Hallo, Windows?
Okay, abtippen, äh, äh, sechs, acht, minus age, 35, also, das da, mal 35, dann haben wir 2,415.
Okay, und das muss ich jetzt einfach nur zusammenrechnen, eats.
42,27, das ist aber ganz schön viel, aber ich hab's richtig gerechnet, oder?
Ich hab's, ich hab's richtig gerechnet, wie war der andere Link, den jemand geschickt hat?
Achso, das ist nicht Prozent, sondern nur ein Zwischenwert.
Wo haben wir, wo war der andere Link jetzt noch mal?
Hier, ne, ne, doch, das ist, äh, Moment, Moment, äh, was haben wir da, oder, ausgerechnet jetzt?
Moment, das ist nicht Fettprozent, das ist Total Bodywater.
Das kann nicht sein.
Ich hab, ich besteh nicht nur aus 42% Wasser.
Das wär ein bisschen wenig, oder?
Das, ach, das ist in Kilo.
Also, also, ich bestehe, ja, aber das ist ja noch weniger.
Also, es wären dann, also das da, Alter, kann man, warum kann man das hier nicht kopieren?
Ah, das ist Kilo Wasser, aber von 104 oder von 105 Wasser?
Was zum Geier ist das, das ist ja echt huge Brain, was man hier braucht.
Okay, also, jetzt, jetzt rechne ich.
Ne, was?
Ah ja, okay, jetzt muss ich erstmal den FFM ausrechnen.
Was auch immer der FFM ist.
Okay, also, müssen wir FFM ausrechnen.
Äh, FFM ist quasi das da.
Okay, also, FFM ist das da durch 0,73.
Äh, Moment.
Warum ist das da auf einmal gleich, ach, das ist das Beispiel, was wir da oben ausgerechnet haben.
Okay, also, das ist, das ist TBW.
So, und jetzt, und jetzt können wir hier unten die FFM ausrechnen.
Okay, dazu rechnen wir jetzt aus.
Äh, das da, das, okay, war alles klar.
Das da, also, Gewicht, Gewicht haben wir jetzt hier.
Ähm, Minus F, P.
Sagt, wenn ich irgendeinen Mist mache, das da, das ist quasi die FFM.
So, und jetzt, jetzt kann ich das ausrechnen.
Was, TBW ist 42?
Was habe ich falsch gemacht?
Hä?
Aber ich muss jetzt FFM aus, muss jetzt mit FFM rechnen.
Jetzt, jetzt habt ihr mich verwirrt.
Ach, Moment, das habe ich noch gar nicht ausgerechnet, oder?
Das, das habe ich, das habe ich noch gar nicht, das habe ich noch gar nicht ausgerechnet.
Doch.
Ach, das ist FFM, genau.
Also, das da.
Minus das da.
Hab ich doch.
Rechne ich doch richtig alles.
Okay, dann ist das die FFM.
Und jetzt machen wir das da.
Also, jetzt machen wir im Endeffekt, machen wir jetzt das hier.
Ähm, also, das da.
Fisch 104 mal 100.
Das da.
Okay.
Das heißt, heute richtiger Kekonastream.
Von dem ursprünglichen Wert hat sich jetzt aber nicht so viel geändert, oder?
Stimmt das, was ich ausgerechnet habe?
Okay, ich habe keine Ahnung, ob das stimmt.
Aber gehen wir einfach mal von aus, richtiger Kekonastream heute.
44% ist doch komplett unrealistisch, ja.
Gucken wir mal, gucken wir mal.
Body fat table.
Die Waage zeigt nichts an.
Weil die Waage nur mit der App, äh, Körperfat anzeigt.
Okay.
Also, Body fat table.
Ist aber übelst ungenau, das kann sein, aber so ungefähr.
Okay.
Okay, wir sind über, warte, warte.
Okay, Leute, guck mal, wir sind über, wir sind über, überdurchschnittlich.
Das weiß ich auch.
Guck mal, die Tabelle geht überhaupt nicht so weit.
MonkaS, out of scale.
Wo, wo erkennt man jetzt hier überhaupt was?
Total body fat, Prozent, hier.
Da sind wir.
Ach, woman all ages, nee.
Gibt's das, gibt's das nicht noch irgendwie ein bisschen, bisschen mehr scale?
Hier, oh, die scale ist gut, huge scale.
Die brauchen wir.
Okay, was ist das denn jetzt?
Oh, hier sind wir, guck mal.
Was?
Ach nee, das ist Bauchumfang.
For woman, die sind anscheinend.
Man.
Oh, hier Kokona.
Guck mal.
Huge Kokona Stream.
Ja, das kommt schon ungefähr hin.
Na ja, also, wenn man, wenn man ab 25 Prozent schon zu dick ist.
Und das Ding sagt irgendwie, ich hätte was.
In 44, da müsste ich ja, da müsste ich ja huge fat sein.
Also, also quasi so, ich kann nicht mal gerade ins Klo reinlaufen.
Ja, so ungefähr.
Ey, okay, so wirklich gescheite Sachen finden tue ich jetzt hier nicht.
Ich mein, das hier ist age.
Hier bin ich.
So, das dürfte ich haben.
Ach nee, das ist was anderes.
Das ist irgendwas anderes.
Ja, genau.
Okay, so genau wird man da aus der Sache nicht schlau.
Na gut, für Kerle wird es ähnlich sein.
Ich weiß, wie wenige essen mehr bewegen.
Das ist jetzt ja nicht so, als wüsste ich das nicht.
Okay, nice.
Also Leute, wir haben es geschafft.
Warum habe ich meine Vm geschlossen?
Hier ist die Vm.
Wir haben es geschafft, Leute.
Wir wissen Bescheid.
Die Waage per Bluetooth funktioniert.
Und dann, was sagt er mir?
Er sagt dann, ah ja, sie sind zu dick.
Und dann sage ich dann, echt jetzt, wäre ich nie drauf gekommen.
Er sagt, er sagt, futter weniger und bewege dich mehr.
Das ist ja das Einzige, was hilft im Endeffekt.
Du kannst noch so viele Big Brain Geschichten machen.
Aber das Einzige, was hilft, ist bewegen, Sport machen und weniger essen.
Oder sehr viel mehr Sport machen und gleich viel essen.
Übrigens, das speichere ich mir mal.
Das kann nämlich durchaus sein, dass ich das mal in meine Heimautomatisierung einrechne.
Dass der mir quasi im Startbildschirm anzeigt.
Also ich habe mir das so gedacht, der ESP, da kommt dann halt,
ich brauche gar keinen neuen ESP, fällt mir gerade ein,
weil im Prinzip, ich habe ja schon genug rumhängen.
Da kann das einer von denen mitmachen.
Nee, geht ja nicht.
Ich muss ja dieses OpenMQTT-Gateway flaschen.
Und dann stelle ich mich da jeden Morgen mal drauf und gucke,
dass ich das wieder hinkriege, bis März, April wieder unter 100.
Ich habe schon richtig Kokonat an Weihnachten.
Ich habe Massive Kokona gemacht.
Ja, mit dem Fahrrad zur Arbeit, dafür ist es ein Ticken weit.
Es ist ein Ticken weit.
Ich kann euch mal zeigen, wie weit das ist.
Also so ungefähr.
Ich zeige es euch jetzt nicht.
Plätzchen, ja alles Mögliche.
Ich zeige euch jetzt nicht, wo genau.
Aber ich zeige euch mal ungefähr, von wo ich fahren müsste.
Sagen wir es einfach mal von hier,
wo es jetzt hier anzeigt, nach Frankfurt Südbahnhof.
Oder keine Ahnung, da starten wir jetzt mal.
Ach so, Fahrrad.
Das ist zu weit für jemand, der untrainiert ist.
Das kann er nicht machen.
Da brauche ich drei Stunden bis ich da bin oder so.
Das ist zu weit.
Das kann ich höchstens einmal auf der Woche im Heimweg machen.
Kauft ihr halt ein elektrisches Fahrrad.
Also wenn man so in 40 Minuten dahin fahren könnte, ist okay, aber das ist zu weit.
Weil wenn ich in 40, 45 Minuten dahin fahren könnte,
ein bisschen untrainiert, dann wäre okay, aber so ist zu weit.
Eine Stunde zwölf.
Selbst wenn ich, selbst jemand, der wahrscheinlich super gut Fahrrad fährt,
der fährt das vielleicht in einer Stunde.
Das ist zu...
Kannst du im Office duschen?
Theoretisch schon, aber ich habe halt überhaupt nichts dabei.
Also keine Handtücher oder sonst irgendwas.
Würdest du dann theoretisch auch alles mitnehmen.
Max, wie alt bist du? 35.
Aber heute haben wir wieder richtig massive Quick Muffs gemacht.
Ist doch das, was ich sage.
Das hat funktioniert.
Wie gesagt, ich habe jetzt schon die letzten eineinhalb Wochen nichts mittags gegessen.
Oder selten mittags gegessen.
Und schon ist es über einen Kilo weniger.
Das geht am Anfang auch relativ zackig.
Ich war selten über 100 und jetzt ist halt seit diesem Weihnachten
Massive Kokona angesagt.
Ich war halt einen Monat daheim.
Ich habe halt so viel gefressen.
Ich habe bestimmt drei Kilo zugenommen oder so im Dezember.
So ein L-Stream auf dem Fahrrad hätte was.
Ich weiß ja nicht.
Wie groß bist du? 1,75.
Ja, Justin, das geht schnell.
Okay.
So, wenn wir erstmal Kokona löschen, so einfach kann es sein.
Und schon sind wir nicht mehr dick.
Nocha, genau.
Das habe ich schon ewig nicht mehr gehört.
78 Kilo auf 1,92 ist nicht so viel, leider.
Ein Reh in der Landschaft.
Wo ich immer Bedenken habe, als ich morgens von einem größeren Bahnhof losgefahren bin,
da ist immer einer an mir vorbeigelaufen.
Die war, keine Ahnung, 1,60 oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, was die gewogen hat, aber die war so dünn.
Und die ist immer an mir vorbeigelaufen morgens,
immer gerade zu dem Zeitpunkt, wenn der ICE durchgefahren ist.
Und ich hatte teilweise echt Bedenken, der Fahrtwind reißt die mit.
So dünn ist die gewesen.
Das kann mir nicht passieren.
War die süß, das habe ich mir nicht so genau, also eher weniger.
Die war halt echt, an der war absolut gar nichts dran.
Wahrscheinlich so ein Oberarmumfang wie mein Daumen.
So, was war denn jetzt noch?
Also das mit der Waage hat gut funktioniert.
Was hat denn YouTube so zu bieten?
The worst fake speedrun on YouTube.
Okay.
Wer hat wieder gefaked, wer hat wieder gefaked, Leute?
Das ist ein Kackvideo.
Warum?
Ich habe deine Reaktion auf den Gartenstells hochgeladen,
darauf kannst du reagieren, also sprich, du meinst jetzt,
nur dass ich das richtig verstehe, Michael, du sagst jetzt,
ich soll reagieren auf meine Reaktion, wo ich zu meinem Video reaktiert habe.
Das ist über einen spanischen YouTuber, der Content klaut.
The most expensive keyboard I have ever unboxed.
Was kann man noch machen?
Erst noch Papierkorb leeren.
Stellenanzeigen, Stellenanzeigen haben wir lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Das stimmt.
Da gucken wir mal Stellenanzeigen.
Das haben wir wirklich schon lange nicht mehr gemacht.
Bildschirmarbeiter, sechs Monate, Dankeschön.
Mein Meme-Tool hängt.
Was mache ich denn jetzt?
Natürlich hängt das nicht.
Ich gucke mal hier und bei denen.
Also da muss ich gucken, ich weiß, dass da mein Arbeitgeber auch drin ist.
Der muss ich dann halt da unauffällig skippen, wenn ich ihn finde.
In Frankfurt.
30 Kilometer.
Scheißegal.
Wir machen mal.
Wir machen 60329.
Und dann sagen wir Kilometerwald in Frankfurt.
Ich weiß auch, dass die Bahn viele Sachen sucht.
Übrigens habe ich euch gezeigt, die Telekom möchte mich anwerben.
Pass mal auf, wo sieht man und wo kann man sich hier anzeigen lassen?
Inklusive Antworten.
Ach hier.
What?
Okay, da haben wir was anderes da.
Latest.
Ja.
Die Telekom.
Pass mal auf, ich hoffe, ihr habt es nicht gesehen.
Jetzt pass mal auf, ich zeige euch mal was.
Das ist ein Video für Telekom, Stellenanzeigen, dass die Leute suchen und wie geil es bei der Telekom ist.
Pass mal auf, bei 20 Sekunden.
Anti-Huge-Prains unter euch.
Was seht ihr hier?
Außer das Grill.
Sauce-Code meine ich.
Was, was, Moment, was seht ihr hier?
Weil Grill im Bild, Chat kann immer richtig denken.
C, sehr gut.
Das ist aus der Linux-Userverwaltung.
Das erkenne ich daran, dass hier öfters, wo steht es denn, Group-Info drin steht und irgendwo steht auch noch was von...
Was ist das denn?
Warte mal.
Alter, der Schmatzer geht mir auf den Sack.
Hier, Group-Info-Blocks.
Das ist Linux-Userverwaltung, Sauce-Code.
Das weiß ich aber auch nur, weil ich auf GitHub danach gesucht habe.
Und das erste, was einem da auffällt, ist, dass das ziemlich ein Fail ist, der nicht funktioniert.
Und ich bin mir sicher, die haben das Copy-Pasted aus.
Also erstmal fehlt hier, da fehlt ein Return, da fehlt ein Semikolon und das heißt nicht Return Group, sondern es muss Return Group-Info heißen.
Und ich wette mit euch, die haben das hierher kopiert.
Kommt's euch bekannt vor, Leute?
Kommt euch das bekannt vor?
Nicht im Ernst? Naja.
Doch.
Guck mal, ich komme auch drin vor.
Was haben die hierher kopiert? Die haben einfach Hacker-Typer kopiert.
Mit dem Unterschied, dass die Return Group...
Mit dem Unterschied, dass die nicht richtig Copy-Pasted haben, dass die irgendwie so hier Copy-Pasted haben und die Hälfte nicht mitkopiert haben.
Das habe ich denen ja auch geschrieben und danach kommen sie mit...
Aber wir gucken mal, ob offene Stellen bei der Telekom für mich dabei sind.
Kommt, wir gucken jetzt mal, wir gucken uns das jetzt mal an, was die gepostet haben.
Und was auch witzig ist, die schreiben hier diese Präzession.
Und da kam natürlich schon mal der...
Der Big Brain Typ als Antwort und hat gesagt...
Ihr sucht die Richtungsänderung, die die Rotationsachse eines rotierenden Körpers kreist und ausführt eine äußere Kraft, ein Drehmoment senkrecht zu diesen Achsen aus.
Das ist...
Das ist Präzession. Was die meint, ist Präzession.
Das meinen die?
Ja, gut.
Da, mit einem S, genau.
Doch, so, genau. Ist aber auch scheißegal im Endeffekt, bockerwurst.
Wir gucken uns mal an, ob da was dabei wäre für mich.
Also wenn mir die Telekom schon vorschlägt, ich soll es für ihn, dann gucken wir uns doch mal an, was dabei ist.
Stichwort, Stellensuche in...
Kann man das nicht? Lokalisiere mich, genau.
Lokalisiere mich.
Jawoll.
Also wir haben drei Stellen in Häusenstamm bei der Telekom.
Und zwar...
Ist ein bisschen schlecht aligned hier oben, dieses Ding.
Adresse League, OMG.
Genau da, genau da hier, Leute.
Also was? Bachelor of Science in Wirtschaftsinformatik.
IT-System Elektroniker und IT-System Kaufmann.
Warum genau in Häusenstamm?
Ok, und in Niederrad, da weiß ich sogar, wo das ist hier.
Das ist... Wo ist denn der Südbahnhof?
Oder, oder, warte mal, warte mal. Nee, nee, nee, ich komm... Quatsch.
Sachs nach Hause, der Südbahnhof. Nee, warte mal, wo ist der Südbahnhof?
Südbahnhof ist weiter oben.
Hier ist der Südbahnhof.
Ähm...
So.
Ja, doch, doch, ich weiß, wo das ist.
Hier suchen sie Zeug. Also was suchen sie hier?
Den Account Manager Banking und... Ja, genau.
Genau das Richtige für mich.
Chemie und Pharma in...
Was macht die Telekom eigentlich alles?
Sollte die Telekom sich nicht um Telefonanschlüsse und Internetausbau kümmern?
Monka League. Das hab ich mir schon aufgeschrieben bei Emotes.
Health Industry.
Account Manager Logistics Mobility.
Das können die nicht, deswegen andere Bereiche. Ach so.
Aber es ist schon mal wichtig, dass das alles richtig stylische Namen hat.
Senior IT Account Manager.
Telco Industry. Telco Industry. SAP.
Gehste fort.
Wie viele Modes kannst du machen? Oh, ich war 20 oder so. 24. 24, glaube ich.
Wir hatten doch mal geguckt.
Junior Consultant Executive Support.
Telefonieren mit Endkunden.
SAP Berater. SAP.
Connected Car Platforms. Frontend Architekt.
Es riecht so nach Javascript.
G-Stalls 90. Twitch Prime. Dankeschön. SAP.
Microservice Architekt. Ok, zeig mal her.
Senior Account Manager. Junior Technical Consultant für PaaS, Edge und Big Data.
Was genau macht man als Junior Technical Consultant für PaaS, Edge und Big Data?
Das muss ich mir mal angucken. Ich will einfach nur wissen, was die darunter verstehen.
Scheiße Namen. Ja gut, das musst du beahlen.
Oh Senior. Senior kommt auch noch. In meinem Alter muss ich...
Ich bin ja sowas von Monka Old schon. Senior natürlich. Ich bin eigentlich schon...
Ich komme nach Senior. Ich bin Rentner Consultant.
Guru. Dead Consultant.
Senior Pro... Nein, sowas mache ich garantiert nicht.
Lead Consultant. Integrated Lifecycle Management.
Also wenn die damit sowas... Continuous Integration. Sonst war es in der Richtung vielleicht.
Was ich mir sonst mal angucke.
Tribe Lead. Meinen die mit Tribe wirklich so ein Stamm?
Damit Stamm gemeint?
Stammleiter?
Ist das sowas wie ein Team? Ist das sowas wie ein Teamleiter?
Tribe Leader?
Stammesführer?
Senior IT Consultant. Was macht man da so bei der Telekom?
SAP. Also so viel SAP hier. Muss los.
Migrationsberater. Senior IT Architektur.
Okay, schauen wir mal. Das war jetzt das hier.
Und wo war das andere?
Ah, jetzt da unten.
Vielleicht sind hier mehr die Leute mit Technikbezug.
Guck mal, hier sind die mehr mit Technikbezug.
Aber die Seite ist irgendwie schlecht aligned.
Okay, wir gucken jetzt erstmal die anderen Sachen. Also was möchten Sie als Frontend Architekt haben?
Als Frontend Architekt gestalten Sie die evolutionäre Weiterentwicklung der deutschen Telekom.
Ah, ja. Alles klar. Alles klar. Alles klar.
Mehr, das reicht nicht.
Das ist auch wichtig bei so einer Seite. Die hat bestimmt eine huge brain Frontend Architekt designt, diese Seite.
Dass man bei einer Seite, die lang genug zum Scrollen ist, nochmal die wichtigsten Informationen erst ausklappen muss.
Wahrscheinlich brauchen Sie deswegen Frontend Architekt, weil die Seite so suckt.
Okay, Sie entwickeln und gestalten die IT-Landschaft anhand künftiger Büsse und bla bla bla bla. Sie nutzen Multispeed-Architekturen.
Leute, da hört es bei mir schon auf. Ich habe keine Ahnung, was dieser Satz überhaupt bedeuten soll.
Sie nutzen Multispeed-Architekturen, um schnell und flexibel auf geschäftliche Anforderungen reagieren. Was bedeutet das überhaupt?
Die meinen damit bestimmt nicht verschiedene Netzwerkkabel. Man weiß es nicht.
Multispeed-Architekturen, das ist irgendwie so ein bescheuertes BWL-Wort, garantiert.
Die Leute verdienen ja Geld damit, dass sie sich ganz nach Bullshit ausdenken. Der fobs in einer Two-Speed-Architektur.
Alter, dieses dumme Geschwätze geht mir so auf den Sack. Können die alle nicht mehr einfach sagen, was Sache ist, anstatt immer nur heiße Luft zu fabrizieren?
Multispeed-Architekturen, wir kriegen jetzt die Definition im Chat.
Da bin ich jetzt viel schlauer. Da bin ich jetzt No-Skiller. Danach, nachdem ich das gelesen habe, bin ich jetzt viel schlauer.
Okay, also, die Gestalten... Scheiße. Technische Scheiß. Das ist definitiv nichts für mich.
Was genau hat das mit Frontend-Architekt eigentlich zu tun, wenn ich mal blöd war? Was meinen die mit Frontend eigentlich?
Das ist definitiv nichts für mich. Das ist zu viel BWL-Bullshit dabei. Moment, Bonn? Frankfurt, ja.
Also, jetzt kommt der Microservice-Architekt. Achso, siehe Anforderungen rechts. Aber auch noch, stimmt. Ihr Profil.
Sie bringen mindestens vier Jahre Erfahrung als Frontend-Architekt mit. Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil ich noch nicht mal weiß, was es überhaupt bedeuten soll, was da drüben steht.
Darüber hinaus kennzeichnen sie ausgeprägte Kenntnisse in der Entwicklung von technischen Lösungsansätzen und Architekturen im Umfeld von Frontend-Methodiken.
Ich weiß, das ist so viel heiße Luft in einem Text.
Ausgeprägte Kenntnisse von Enterprise-Portalen und Apps. WTF? Was haben Enterprise-Portalen und Apps mit dem ganzen anderen Kram zu tun, was sie da geschrieben haben?
Steht da eigentlich, wie viel Geld es gibt? Gehalt? Money? Also, dieses Stellenprofil, das muss Zusammenarbeit sein aus irgendeinem Personalmensch und irgendeinem Consultant-Typ, der ihm gesagt hat, was er schreiben soll.
Ich mein, via REST? What? Was zum Teufel sollen wir diese Stellenanzeige sagen?
Was zum Teufel hat REST damit zu tun? Also, ich hoffe mal, die verstehen unter REST das Gleiche wie ich. Also REST-Full-HTTP-AP-Geschichten.
Aber selbst wenn die REST-Full-HTTP-Geschichten meinen, hat das mit dem REST überhaupt nichts zu tun? Was zum Teufel? Das ist komplett wir.
Das ist komplett wir. Das ist wie aus einem Random-Generator das Ding. Weißt du, das hier ist ja noch irgendwie was Technisches, aber der REST überhaupt nicht.
Okay. Was denn das hier noch? Ist das hier auch von der Seite?
Okay. Ja, was denn nun? Soll ich mich mit REST auskennen oder soll ich moderieren auf der Manager-Ebene? Ja, was denn? Alter, ist das ein Bullshit.
Das würde ich im Leben nicht machen. Benefits, Teilzeit möglich, flexible Arbeitszeiten, Weiterbildungsangebote, betriebliche Altersvorsorge, Mitarbeiterabwarte.
Die letzten zwei Sachen sind gut. Der Rest ist, Teilzeit möglich, würde ich mittlerweile eigentlich fast schon mal vorausgehen, ist bei den meisten größeren der Fall.
Flexible Arbeitszeiten ist je nachdem, wie es ausgelegt ist, ein Vorteil oder ein Nachteil, je nachdem, was sie darunter verstehen. Eigentlich eher ein Vorteil.
Aber es kann damit natürlich auch gemeint sein, flexible, zwei Stunden, dafür dann am Samstag, was auch immer. Aber es ist eigentlich eher ein Vorteil.
Oder je nachdem, wie die das ausbilden. Weiterbildungsangebote ist eigentlich auch Standard, je nachdem, was sie darunter verstehen. Okay, aber, Alter, was eine bescheuerte Anzeige.
Moment, Reiseanteil 25-50%. Nope. Never. 25-50% Reiseanteil. Wollte ich mich verarschen? Da bin ich ja nie daheim.
Und dann am besten auch mit der Bahn, ja. Okay, jetzt kommt der Microservice-Architekt.
Mit dem Arsch offen bei der anderen Sache. Also das war echt der Witz. Okay, also was kommt denn bei der Microservice-Architekt?
Als Microservice-Architekt gestalten sie die evolutionäre Weiterentwicklung der deutschen Telekom. Schau mal da. Die ist aber ganz schön revolutionär, evolutionär, was auch immer.
Wie oft das da geschaltet wird. Meine Güte. Das meckert gerade, dass... Mein Unify meckert gerade, dass ich meinen Access-Point updaten soll.
Und WTF? Warum soll ich jetzt mitten im Stream meinen Access-Point updaten?
So, erstmal Unify zumachen. Okay, weiter geht's. Also Microservice-Architektur. Blablabla. Sie arbeiten in einem dynamischen Team.
Und handeln als Vertrauen zu ihren Partnern. Blablabla. Agil, agil, agil. Die Entwicklung gestalten in der IT-Line alle künftig. Aber okay, das ist kleines Multi... Ah, der Bullshit steht bei allen Sachen dabei.
Jetzt verstehe ich auch, warum das so wir ist. Das ist irgendein Basic-Template, was sich mal ein Konsultentyp aus den Fingern gesaugt hat zusammen mit der Personalabteilung.
Und das kommt jetzt in alles rein, wo Architektur drinne steht. Also im Prinzip ist das hier wahrscheinlich das Interessantere. Sie gestalten den Rahmen mithilfe neuer Gaffern. Das ist genau das Gleiche. Ja, das ist auch das Gleiche.
Die Arme einer Maßnahme zukünftig von Frontend-Architektur für Web und App. Hätte das hier... Haben die das vertauscht? Sag mal, haben die das vertauscht? Ah, nee, nee, das steht hier auch drinne. Moment, das ist exakt das Gleiche, was bei beiden drinne steht. Frontend-Architekt und Microservice-Architekt.
Da steht ja exakt das Gleiche drin. Deswegen beliesst sich das auch so wir. Okay, sie verfügen aber mindestens zwei Jahre als Enterprise-Architekt. Natürlich, natürlich. Darüber hinaus kennzeichnen sie ausgeprägte Kenntnisse in der Entwicklung von Technik...
... Frontend, Microservices, KI und deren Umsetzung in großen Projekten. Ja, weil es auch so viele Leute gibt, die zwei Jahre Erfahrung darin haben, eine KI in großen Projekten umzusetzen. Ganz bestimmt. Ja, so sieht's aus.
Was darf es denn sonst noch sein? Unter 20. In den benannten Bereichen verfügen sie über die polnisch ausgeprägte Kenntnisse... OpenShift, Kubernetes oder Ähnliches. Oder Ähnliches. Kann, ja gut.
Ich hab Docker... Das müsste man echt da mal machen. Man müsste da mal so ne richtige... Ohne Scheiß, man müsste da ne richtige G-Bate Bewerbung mal hinschreiben. So mit Fake-Name oder so.
Und dann... Das müssten wir machen. Ich schreib da... Ich muss mir nur gucken, wie ich die Antwort da drauf bekommen kann. Man kann sich da bestimmt online bewerben, oder? Man kann sich da doch garantiert online bewerben.
Ich würd da so gerne ne G-Bate Bewerbung hinschreiben. So nach dem Motto. Ja, ich hab schon mal Docker auf meinem Raspberry Pi installiert.
Aus meinem reichhaltigen Erfahrung, Schatz, bediene ich auch komplexe Aufgaben im Bereich Microservices und Frontend-Architektur. Dank meiner jahrelangen Erfahrung mit Docker auf meinem Raspberry Pi...
Das müsste man echt da mal so ne übelste G-Bate... Ich frag mich, ob was da passiert... Na, du wirst direkt raus... Da macht sich noch gar keiner mal die Mühe, oder wenigstens das überhaupt zu checken.
Das schreib ich immer auf. Ich probier mal irgendeine Fake-Bewerbung bei der Telekom zu machen.
Ich würd's halt absichtlich so schreiben, dass das mega-tubated ist. Also offensichtlich tubated ist.
So nach dem Motto, ich hab Docker auf dem Raspberry Pi installiert und ich hab schon mal nen Ubuntu Linux installiert auf nem alten Notebook. Irgendwie sowas.
Okay, also wie geht's denn hier weiter? Gute Erfahrung mit Datenbank... Ne, mit Datenmanagementmethoden... Was? Gute Erfahrung mit Datenmanagementmethoden im Umgang mit Microservice-Technologien.
Ich habe legit keine Ahnung, was sie mir damit sagen wollen. Datenmanagementmethoden im Umgang mit Microservice... Meinen die damit sowas wie Cosmos DB in Azure oder was?
Aber ich hab legit keinen Schimmer. Aber gut, ich mein, ganz einfach, wenn ich das nicht weiß, dann kann ich... Ich weiß das ja nur nicht, weil ich keine zwei Jahre Erfahrung in KI-Entwicklung hab.
Pech. Also, praktische Fähigkeiten... Okay, man soll wieder auf Management-Ebene moderieren, die können sich auch nicht entscheiden. Aber wenigstens keine Reise. Junior... Den überspringen wir, wir machen den Senior.
Den Senior. Man müsste sagen... Wisst ihr, was wir machen müssten? Was wir da reinschreiben müssten? Sie schreiben doch hier was mit Rest und sagen, ja, ich hab meine Bewerbung mit Curl versendet.
Senior Technical Consultant für Path, Edge oder Big Data. Ah, yes. Exzellent. Okay, keine Karriere-Level Professional.
Also, weiter geht's. Als Technical Presales Manager mit... Ja, was denn jetzt? Suchen die jemanden Berater für Technik in Platform, Azure oder Big Data? Oder suchen die einen Presales Manager?
Nicht, dass ich jetzt exakt benennen könnte, was ein Presales Manager tut, aber Presales Manager klingt eigentlich wie jemand, der die Sachen quasi vor dem Verkauf den Leuten schmackhaft macht oder so.
Ich hab keinen Schermer, was es sein soll. Also, mit dem Schwerpunkt Path, Big Data... Ich sag immer, ich sag lieber Platform, Azure oder Big Data. Path klingt einfach unglaublich dumm ausgesprochen.
Okay, das ist genau das Gleiche. Entwicklung von Path, Big Data, Edge Lösungsarchitekturen. Ich bin mir noch nicht ganz sicher, mit was sie Edge genau meinen.
Ich schiebe es in Interconnect Netzwerkrichtung, aber so wirklich sicher bin ich mir da nicht, was die Telekom da genau drunter versteht.
Beantwortung von Ausschreibung im Cloud-Anwendungsbetrieb. Präsentation... Okay, da hab ich keinen Bock drauf.
Ich laber ja ganz gerne, und ich hab mich ja sogar bei uns in der Firma freiwillig für so ein komisches Laber-Ding angemeldet, aber das ist glücklicherweise vorbei, das war schon Ende letzten Jahres vorbei.
Aber da hab ich keinen Bock drauf, weil da muss man auch, wenn die größten Deppen vor dir sitzen, noch versuchen, quasi denen was zu verkaufen.
Also im Prinzip liest sich das wie jemand, der eigentlich keine Ahnung haben muss, allerdings gut so tun können muss, als hätte er Ahnung.
Um quasi so auf einer Wellenlänge mit den Entscheidungspositionen der Kunden zu sein.
Das wär was für Niklas, für unseren ehemaligen Special Azubi gewesen. Das konnte der gut, das konnte der echt gut.
Der hat ein Talent dafür gehabt, die ersten fünf Minuten dich von einem Thema überzeugen zu können, dass er Ahnung hat, ohne dass er den leisen Schimmer davon hatte.
Es hat halt, das funktioniert aber nur, wenn man selbst keine Ahnung von dem Thema hat. Wenn man sich selbst mit dem Thema auskennt und er anfängt zu erzählen, dann sagst du gleich schon so mal, denkst du ich hab davon auch nie was gehört?
Also Erstellung von Kalkulationen und, oh Gott, nein hör mal auf. Technische Pilotierung von unseren Pass-Lösungen.
Meine Güte. Entwicklung und Demonstration zum Kundenzweck, technische Betreuung und blablabla.
Messen und Konferenz mit dir, immer schlimmer. Ach du Scheiße.
Einbindung und Abschirmung mit allen Querschnittsbereinigungen. Nee, nee, nee, Leute garantiert nicht.
Abgeschlossene, mehr als zwei Jahre Berufsverfahren, alles klar. Kenntnis in DC-Infra-Data-Center. Könnte ich sich einfach ausschreiben, Abkürzungen, Abkürzungen, das könnte auch Gleichstrom sein.
Abkürzungen sind immer so doppeldeutig. Gute Kenntnisse in Data-Center-Infrastructure-Assist-Service. Also im Prinzip reden wir hier von der Magenta Cloud.
Cloudtechnik wie OpenStack vor allem. Hyperscaler-Plattform. AWS, Asher, OTC.
Oh, es tut weh, es ist Schmerz, Alter. Hyperscaler-Plattform, ist klar. Was ist denn OTC? Das ist Amazon, das ist Microsoft, das ist OTC-Cloud, habe ich noch nie was von gehört.
Telekom-Cloud, was denn sonst? Kein Wunder, dass es keine Sau kennt, das ist die Telekom-Cloud. Die glauben doch nicht ernsthaft, dass sich jemand mit zwei Jahren Erfahrung in der Telekom-Cloud meldet.
Die Frage, die sich mir hier stellt ist, übrigens eins muss ich nochmal, Disclaimer, jetzt auch wenn ich mich hier drüber lustig mache über die ganze Geschichte.
Es könnte durchaus sein, dass unter der Haube tatsächlich ein guter, spannender, eventuell sogar gut bezahlter Job steckt.
Allerdings ist das hier absolut nicht rauszuerkennen. Das kann sein, dass der eigentliche Job gar nicht so viel hier mit zu tun hat und wirklich interessant ist.
Das muss ich jetzt nochmal sagen, kann ja sein.
Okay, next. Lead-Consult, oh das ist hier schon. Leute, wir haben nur noch heute Zeit uns zu bewerben. Schnell.
Sie sind ready to design a huge leap for customers. Was? Bewerbung ist raus.
Viele Kunden aus den Bereichen Luft, Raumfahrt, Verteidigung. Demnächst muss ich auch Drohnenangriffe fliegen oder was?
Ziel ist das Prozess, okay wenn ich das, das will ich, das mach ich nicht, das mach ich nicht, vergiss es.
Und die Organisation, was ein Geschwätze alter. Geh mal fort.
Branchen Know-How, Luftfahrt, Luft- und Raumfahrt und Verteidigung. Ich kann 360 Quickscopes machen, das ist eigentlich doch schon mal nicht verkehrt oder?
Also ich finde, ich kann die am meisten verbreiteten Sturmgewehre, kann ich am Sound erkennen.
Ich kucke just for fun. Ich bin natürlich immer offen für Sachen. Also wenn es wirklich irgendwas richtig Gutes gibt, wäre ich nicht abgeneigt da drüber nachzudenken zumindest.
Aber ich bin nicht wirklich auf der Suche.
Moment, was hab ich da gesehen? First Level? Stand da First Level? Hab ich das gesehen? Ah nee, Englisch. Okay, das kann ich, geht nicht.
Also ich weiß nicht, was muss man dafür können? Was ist denn Englisch? Englisch was? Englisch?
CEF Level 1, was ist das? Also ich meine, ich kann mit Leuten auf Englisch reden, die verstehen mich, ich verstehe sie, aber ich hab keine Ahnung was CEF 1 ist.
CEF ist das Chrome Embedded Framework. Fast Muttersprache, nein. Nope. Okay, jetzt kommt das Stammesführer. Das Stammesführer.
Das Stammes, äh, der Häuptling. Stammes Häuptling, suchen sie. Das hab ich ja ehrlich gesagt nur aufgemacht, weil Zulul, Endessei, Endessei, Endessei, Endessei, wie von Zulul.
Ähm, also das hab ich ja nur aufgemacht, weil ich wissen will, was es ist. Da würde ich mich nicht wirklich drauf, aber ich will einfach nur wissen, was es ist.
Der geht auf die Jagd, genau, kriegt einen Speer, der kriegt einen Speer in die Hand und wird ins Rechenzentrum geschickt. Auf die Jagd, der Stammesführer.
Ähm, also. Als, okay, okay, ich versuch mal zu verstehen, was es ist. Ich versuch einfach nur zu verstehen, was es ist.
Der Business Area Public. Übernehmen sie eine zentrale Funktion in der Portfolio Unit Dedicated SI Solutions. Was?
Leute, ihr habt mich jetzt schon nach dem ersten, nach dem ersten halben Satz, äh, verloren. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was da steht. Weißt du Bescheid, ja?
Ach du Scheiße. Ich hab gedacht, anhand des Titels, die suchen einen Teamleiter, aber, aber die suchen, ich hab keine Ahnung, was die suchen, aber ein Tribe Stammesanführer.
Keine Ahnung. Die suchen einen, der sich gut verkauft. Ich hab den Eindruck, bei allen Stellenbeschreibungen, die wir bisher gesehen haben von der Telekom, die suchen nur Leute, die keine Ahnung haben, aber sich gut verkaufen können.
Okay, jetzt kommt der Senior IT Consultant. Na hoffentlich muss der ein bisschen Ahnung von Technik haben.
In ihrer Rolle als Senior IT Consultant begleiten sie an unseren Standorten den strategischen Aufbau blablabla.
Ich mein, ich weiß, dass viele Consultants, ich weiß das aus eigener Erfahrung, weil ich das direkt klicklich sehe, eigentlich von Technik überhaupt keinen blassen Schimmer haben.
Aber wenn man sich das Wort mal auf der Zunge zergehen lässt, bedeutet ja, dass jemand, das ist jemand, den ich konsultieren kann, also jemand, den ich fragen kann, also quasi wenn ich selber keine Ahnung mehr habe, kann ich den fragen in diesem Fachgebiet.
So kann man das ja übersetzen. Ich weiß, dass viele IT Consultants absolut planlos sind. Ich sehe das ja tagtäglich bei uns.
Unten ist da ein Geldbild. Wo ist Geld? Hier. Ah, betriebliche Altersvorsorge. Das haben sie bei anderen Sachen auch.
Sie entwickeln unsere zukünftige Geschäftswunder blablabla. Sie spielen an blablabla. Okay, hat mit IT schon mal gar nichts zu tun.
Blablabla. Blablabla. Okay, hat mit Technik absolut nichts zu tun.
Jetzt kommt der Senior IT Architekt kommt jetzt. Was ist der Smileys bei Benefitz?
Das ist ein Benefit. Das ist doch kein Benefit. Das ist Standard. Du musst doch irgendwie einen ordentlichen Start ermöglicht kriegen. Das ist doch kein Vorteil.
Was ist ein Onboarding Prozess, dass du quasi erzählt kriegst, wie der Laden läuft. Anlernen. Einarbeiten ist ein schönes Wort dafür.
Einarbeiten. Du wirst einarbeiten. Du kriegst erklärt, wer ist für was ungefähr zuständig, wohin musst du, wenn was ist. So, wie wenn du in ein Flugzeug gehst.
Man kriegt es auch erstmal erklärt, wo hängen die Westen rum, wie funktioniert alles.
Nein, ein Onboarding ist in dem Fall was anderes. Die meinen damit ziemlich sicher, dass du ordentlich eingearbeitet wirst.
Der Witz ist halt, das sollte die Fault sein. Das ist kein Benefit. Die werden ziemlich blöd, wenn sie mich nicht einarbeiten, weil da kann ich nichts machen.
Gesundheitsangebote. Moment, gucke mal. Der hier. Wo ist denn hier der Unterschied? Ah, Homeoffice wahrscheinlich. Homeoffice, Mobile Working möglich.
Aha, das geht gar nicht bei allen. Ja gut, hier musst du ja auch nur, hier musst du ja auch nur doof labern können. Also, das kann man von der Heimat aus machen.
Steht hier eigentlich irgendwas von Gehalt drinnen? Nö. Aber zumindest mal eine Hausnummer könnte man ja schon mal nennen. Das machen aber alle nicht gerne.
Das ist eigentlich schwätzer. Senior Softwarearchitekt. Ja, suchen sie jetzt einen IT-Architekt oder so einen Softwarearchitekt. Die sind sich oftmals gar nicht so ganz einig in dem, was sie hier unten schreiben und was sie hier oben suchen.
Suchen die eigentlich auch Leute, die wissen, wovon sie reden? Ah doch, hier. Okay, der muss ich schon ein bisschen mit was auskennen.
Fachliche Führungsrolle bei der Arbeit von Digitalisierungslösungen auf Basis von agilen Methoden wie beispielsweise Scrum. Analyse und Erstellung innovativer performanter Architektur und Designlösungen. Aha. Umsetzung, Qualitätssicherung, Lösungen sowie Entscheidungen.
Und modernen Deployment mit Hunden wie DevOps geht. Moment, was? Umsetzung und Qualitätssicherung der Lösung sowie entscheidende Einflussnahme auf die Zusammenarbeit mit dem Betrieb, wenn es um die Cloud und modernen Deployment mit Hunden wie DevOps geht. Aha.
Okay, viel Einfahren von Raum für kreative Ideen heißt im Prinzip, wir haben absolut keinen Schimmer, was man eigentlich machen soll.
UML, ernsthaft? Die Anforderung für einen Softwarearchitekt ist, er kann UML-Diagramme machen. Okay, ich meine UML-Diagramme sind wahrscheinlich bei... Alter, warum?
Das UMS Max sperrt Leute, was hab ich übersehen? Was hab ich übersehen? Was hat er gemacht?
Guck Discord, okay. So, weiter im Text. Guck nebenbei Discord.
So, weiter im Text. Gute Kenntnisse in modernen Softwarearchitekturen. Such-Dingsbums. Das ist doch Such-Maschine-Optimier, oder? Microservices. Wie geht's? Leute, Sie haben es gesagt. Muss das sein?
Was müssen Sie uns wirklich damit quälen?
Serious Max, ich hab's gerade im Chat gesehen. Ja, immer weg mit den Leuten, ja. Was für Leute gibt einer? Hab ich gar nicht gesehen.
Hey Max, ist DSL 100 MBit oder Kabel 100 MBit besser? 100 MBit sind 100 MBit. Macht keinen Unterschied. Okay, also.
So, die wollen Erfahrungen in Java, Webentwicklung mit Java. JPA, ich weiß nicht was das ist, irgendein Java Zeug. JSP ist auch irgendein Java Gedöns. Yes, der kleine Java Angular React. Im Bereich Datenbanken und Kommunikation. Aber mal. Das ist aber mal ein ordentliches Paket, Herr.
Technologisch sind Sie auf dem neuesten Shown und wollen Trends wie IoT oder DevOps in die Preise? Ja, will ich. Leute, ich fühle mich angesprochen. Ich fühle mich angesprochen.
Ich fühle mich zum ersten Mal angesprochen von einem Teil der Stellanzeige.
Erste Erfahrung mit modernen Agilmethoden wie Scrum? Ja, hab ich. Sie übernehmen gerne die Treiberrolle? Nö. Da ist man zu exposed und hat nicht seine Ruhe.
Ich halte es für sehr vorteilhaft, Leute, die komplizierte Probleme lösen mussten, in Ruhe zu lassen, dass sie denken können.
Ich glaube, das ist aber nicht im, wie sagt man so schön, im Scope. Also Leute, die wirklich gute Architekturen erstellen, die komplizierte Abläufe implementieren, die sollte man einfach in Ruhe denken lassen.
Das kannst du aber nicht machen, wenn du permanent irgendwo rumspringen sollst. Funktioniert nicht.
Okay, jetzt kommen wir mal zu den Technik-Jobs bei der Telekom. Master of Science in Informations- und Kommunikation. Wollen die da auch wirklich einen Master haben, weil bei den anderen Jobbezeichnungen, sie können bei den anderen Sachen, weil das ja auch, das lernen sie im Studium. Ach nee. Ach, das ist ein duales Studium.
Ach so. Das ist ein duales Studium. Das ist auch ein duales Studium.
Oh, guck mal, die suchen fiesi Azubis. Da schreiben sie die Vergütung dabei, ja. Aber bei den anderen Sachen nicht.
Okay, also gucken wir uns das Ganze mal an für Leute, die vielleicht vorhaben, bei der Telekom eine Ausbildung zu machen.
Oh Gott, das ist cringe, Alter.
Ich trinke.
Und wie man Nutzer berät und schult. Dieser Teil für Leute, die die Ausbildung machen und falls die Telekom das ernst meint, das wird euch zum Kotzen bringen. End-User-Support ist das undankbarste und nervigste, was man machen kann.
Zu deinen Schwerpunkten zählen...
Zu deinen Schwerpunkten zählen? Während deines Betriebs Einsatze schnupperst du in verschiedene... Hä? Der Überschrift passt nicht zu dem Text.
Okay, das ist komisch zusammencopying und pasting, glaube ich.
Du hast die Wahl. Achso, das da gehört da, das gehört da drunter.
Oh, was ist das für ein Video? Das können wir uns nachher auch noch angucken. Wir haben ja noch ein bisschen Zeit.
Haha, das ist ja witzig. Du hast die Wahl. Möchtest du Systemintegration machen, vielleicht als Systemintegrator? Nee, nee, lieber nicht, lieber nicht.
Anwender, Schulung und Präsentation. Oh, das ist undankbar. Planen, installieren und konfigurieren komplexer IT-System. Ja, sollte dabei sein. Systemintegration Netzwerke sollte auch dabei sein. Serviceberatung und bereinbarung...
Ja, das ist so ein Standardzeug. Schulnoten sind nicht alle... Das finde ich gut, dass ihr das schreibt. Das finde ich gut, dass ihr das schreibt.
Weil viele Leute... Also, ich wäre auch öfter... Da wird ja immer noch öfters gefragt. Ich meine, ich habe da ein paar Videos zu gemacht, das war schon ewig her.
Ob man das mit, keine Ahnung, vier in Mathe sich bewerben kann oder wenn das nicht so gut ist und sonst was. Kann man, kann man.
Ach ja, und Endkundensupport gehört tatsächlich nicht zu so einer Fisi-Geschichte. Aber das ist sehr breit gefächert, wo man da landet.
Aber das finde ich tatsächlich, finde ich gut, dass ihr das schreibt.
Das ist doch gut. Also, da kann man sich bewerben. Doch, da kann man sich echt bewerben, als Fisi, wenn man da Interesse dran hat.
Okay, also, wir haben uns jetzt angeguckt. Die Telekom hat absolut nichts für mich. Ich bin enttäuscht, Telekom.
Ihr habt gesagt, ihr habt vielleicht was für mich und ihr habt nichts. Ich bin enttäuscht von euch, Telekom.
Schickt ihr einen Link? Die Typen auf Twitter-Support, die haben doch damit überhaupt nichts zu tun.
Okay, irgendeiner hat eben ein Video geschickt, Windows schneller machen, mehr FPS für alle Gamer plus Windows Tweaks.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt mal an, dass wir endlich erfahren, wie wir unser Windows schneller machen können.
Alter, was ist das für ein Intro wieder? WTF?
Was zum Teufel ist das für ein Dreck? Okay, Moment, ich muss mal in meine VM. Ich traue mich das nicht, unter Windows aufzumachen.
WTF? Na gut, mal gucken, mal gucken, was da drin ist. Jetzt auf Github. Ja, ich meine immerhin, es ist auf Github, man kann sich angucken, was das macht.
Okay, was auch immer das macht. Okay, wir gucken uns jetzt mal das Video dazu an. Also mal gucken, was da passiert.
Mal ganz davon abgesehen, es ist einfach ein Best-of aus anderen Sachen, aber egal.
Warum? Was ist das für ein GUI überhaupt? Das ist ja Windows Forms und dann noch in hässlich.
Aber er hat ein hübsches Studio, muss ich sagen. Er erinnert mich von dem, wie das angepriesen wird, ein bisschen an die Typen, die mich auf YouTube immer dazu überreden wollen, ihr Steuersparseminar zu buchen. Aber ein schönes Studio ist es.
Und die besten Tuning-Tricks und Tipps, die wir finden konnten. Und noch ein paar Geheimnisse. Schaut rein ins Video, das wird euch umhauen, ich verspreche es.
Ich schwöre, das ist das Beste, was wir je produziert haben. Gut, wir haben es nicht alleine produziert. Wir haben einen coolen Köpen kennengelernt, MinersWin auf Discord, der managt das Ganze auch und hat zusammen mit mir diese GUI und das Projekt zusammengefügt.
Das heißt, wir haben es von Grund auf neu zusammengearbeitet. Es ist nicht wie 3.2 mit Skippen und so weiter. Nein, es ist von Grund auf super geil. Wir haben da Nächte dran gefusselt.
Also natürlich muss man sich das erstmal besorgen. Tuningpack.de könnt ihr auch buchen. Tun-pack.de. Wir haben eine eigene Homepage dafür erstellt. Also ich bin ja immer skeptisch, wenn Sachen schon als das Beste überhaupt angepriesen werden.
Dann sollte man sich vielleicht eher darauf konzentrieren, was das eigentlich macht. Oder über unsere Homepage, da haben wir auch einen eigenen Tag mit Tuningpack 4.0, falls ihr das bevorzugt und uns ein paar Begriffe zukommen lassen wollt.
Weil es bedient sich ja nicht so viel mit YouTube. Wir verbreiten weder Malware, noch Viren.
Der erinnert mich übelst an meinen Zahnarzt. Der redet wie mein Zahnarzt. Jetzt weder positiv, noch negativ. Der fällt mir auch aus, der redet wie mein Zahnarzt.
Wir wollen euren PC verbessern, eure Erfahrung mit Windows. Der redet original wie mein Zahnarzt.
Verbessern, nicht verschlechtern. Wir wollen weder scammen, noch irgendjemanden abzocken. Als richtiges Programm über GitHub mit ganz viel Entwicklung und Support unser Pack.
Gehen wir mal rüber, laden es runter. Hier ist gleich der Download-Button, der ist hier auf der Seite überall noch ein bisschen...
Ok, das Change-Log gucken wir uns dann gleich mal an. Change-Log auf GitHub, das gucken wir uns gleich mal nachher an.
Also zack, runterladen. Wir wollen jetzt speichern, dann wird das Ganze runtergeladen. Juhu, und wir öffnen es auch schon. Da habt ihr es.
Ist das Winra? Es gibt Leute, die doch Winra verwenden. Huge.
Kein 7-Zip oder sonst was. Winra, alter. Bestimmt lizenziert.
Pain Winra. Was ist daran so schlimm? Naja, es ist nix. Nix. Aber es ist halt... Das ist so ein Running Gag mit Winra.
Hey Max, nutzt du zu Hause P-Hole? Pie-Hole? Oder hast du dir einen eigenen DNS gebaut? Benutze Pie-Hole, ja.
Aber ist leider nicht mal so gut wie früher. Aber da können die nix für, sondern weil die Anbieter cleverer geworden sind.
Dann gehen wir jetzt auf unseren Desktop. Wunderbar. Und da ist es auch. Früher Alpha-Version. Wir waren noch mal vor.
Keine Gewährleistung, wir übernehmen keine Verantwortung. Also erst mal implodiert der Rechner.
Wir unterstützen euch gerne im Support Discord. Da haben wir einen ganzen Thread dazu aufgemacht, zu Verbesserungen, zu Vorschlägen, zu Problemen.
Wir haben auch Feedback, dass ihr uns geben wollt zu dem Tuning Pack, dass diese Anregungen auch übernommen werden und uns helfen, euch ein besseres Programm und eine bessere Experience zu verschaffen.
Das ist doch top. Besser Experience. Unser Programm hat einen Auto-Updater. Das heißt, die Updates gehen automatisch mit rein.
Ich frage mich, was das macht. Es ist unter der Haube wahrscheinlich eine Sammlung aus fertigen Programmen und ein paar Registry Hacks, ein paar andere Tunedinger oder so.
Ich weiß nicht. Müssen wir mal gleich gucken, was da drin ist.
Ein neues Update ist verfügbar und es wird gleich aktualisiert. Ist das nicht cool? Wir sagen erst mal okay.
Das GUI, Alter!
Erst mal lesen. Lesen ist das Wichtigste. Also ihr lest euch durch. Wir übernehmen keine Verantwortung. Hier ist ein Invite zum Discord-Channel, dass ihr euch da...
Give me the juice. Oh Gott, das ist so cringe, das Ding hier.
Give me the juice.
Okay, das GUI sieht aus, wie jemand zum ersten Mal, wenn er aus Forms angefasst hat. Zeit will ich böse, aber er sieht nicht nach 2020 aus.
Egal. Das kann ja trotzdem was gescheiteres sein.
Ich muss jetzt mal aufhören. Wir warten erst mal ab. Nicht gleich schlecht, erst mal abfahren.
Vor allem, warum braucht das denn eigentlich ein CMD-Fenster, wenn es doch ein GUI hat? Das ist mal Big Brain, oder?
...da austauschen könnt. Ich bin mir das Regius BU plus und gehe rein. Cool. Was haben wir hier? Registry-Quicks. Dienst...
Okay. Ah, ja. Gut. Also ist im Prinzip das, was ich mir schon gedacht habe. Also eine Sammlung aus bekannten Bots, nicht so bekannten.
Okay. Was haben wir denn? Registry-Hacks. Ja, gut. Das ist... Okay, warum nicht? Ja, ich meine, es ist alles...
Es ist alles in einem, was man vielleicht machen will. Die Sache ist plus die. Hier drinnen findest du sie im Endeffekt auch nicht schneller als die Funktion in Windows.
Weil dieses Zeug kannst du ja auch so alles einstellen.
Gibt es im nächsten Stream dann alle Sourcecode-Bewertungen? Wir gucken uns das an. Oh Leute, wir gucken uns gleich mal das... Das ist garantiert ein.NET WinForms-Ding.
Wir gucken uns den Sourcecode gleich mal an. Falls ich es vergesse, sagt Bescheid. Klarte Aufgaben, andere Tweaks und Werkzeuge.
Also Moment, Moment. Was haben wir da? Internet Explorer Cleanup. Okay, warum? CC Cleaner. Es gibt Leute, die schwören, wie sagt man so schön,
Bein und Stein, Stein und Bein oder sonst was drauf auf CC Cleaner. Ich hab mal im Leben noch nicht CC Cleaner installiert gehabt, aber es mag seine Daseinsberechtigung haben.
Ja, viele schwören da total drauf. Ich verstehe den Sinn zwar nicht so mälich zu sein, weil in Registry musst du nicht cleanen.
Zumindest wenn du nichts komisches machst. Aber in Registry, wo viel drinsteht, die macht den Rechner auch nicht langsam.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Leute auf so eine Idee kommen.
Bleachbit, weiß ich nicht, was es ist. Tempfile Cleanup, würde ich mal vermuten, macht sowas, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Irgendwelche Auslagerungdateien löschen Tempo oder sonst was.
USB Device, Cleanup, keine Ahnung, kann man einfach formatieren. Cleanup, Duplicate, Downloads, okay.
Clear Windows Event Logs, die rotieren doch automatisch. Clear Windows Update Cache, okay das kann man machen.
Mach ein bisschen Platz auf der Platte. AD Spy, habe ich keine Ahnung, was es ist. ADW Cleaner ist auch ein komisches Zeug, was man nicht braucht.
Adware, ASW, MDR, Master Boot Record, ASW, ich weiß nicht, was es ist, Autoranker, PC, Hunter, kein Schimmer.
Net Adapter Repair, das wäre ja cool, wenn ich meine Netzwerkkarte ganz machen könnte.
Einfach mit dem Knopf, Kill Process, wie sieht es mit Prozess Explorer, Eats, Park Control.
Das ist glaube ich, ich glaube Park Control, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, war mal zumindest ein tatsächlich recht sinnvolles Tool.
Das ist für Stromsparmodi von der CPU. Das war mal wirklich sinnvoll, wenn es das ist, was ich denke.
Park Control, ja das war mal ganz sinnvoll, ich weiß nicht, ob man das noch braucht.
MSI Installer Cleanup, Tempdateien, Systemfile Checker, da würde ich, an meine Systemfiles würde ich kein Programm lassen.
Image Checker, Check Disk, das brauchen wir mit SSDs. SSDs segmentieren nicht. Network Repair, File Extensions, ich habe keine Ahnung, was das soll ich alles machen.
Reboot to Recovery, da kann man quasi dieses PE, Windows PE, das soll ich booten.
Ok, Desinfect haben wir noch, Clear, Crypt, Net, SSL Cache, Malware, Bytes, Anti-Malware, das kenne ich, das ist wo man seinen Report an irgendeinem Forum posten kann.
Kaspersky, Virus Removal Tool, Soforce Virus Removal Tool.
Leute jetzt ernsthaft hier, ich sage jetzt mal wie es ist im Stream, wenn ihr den Virus hattet, es gibt nur eine Variante, was ihr machen müsst.
System neu installieren, oder die einzige hilfreiche Variante, System neu installieren.
Plant machen, neu installieren.
Ich würde mich nicht darauf verlassen, dass Aufräumprogramme alles entfernen.
Das erste ist einmal, ihr schaltet aus, ihr startet das Ding mit einer Linux Live CD oder Live USB oder was auch immer, startet ihr das Ding,
kopiert euch die Dateien runter, die ihr braucht, und dann macht ihr das Ding komplett platt.
Und ihr hofft nur, dass die Dateien sauber sind, was bei normalen Programmen jetzt, also wenn es ein Textdatei ist, was soll da groß sein.
Aber das ist das einzige was hilft, sobald ihr Virusinfektion hattet, weg.
So, wir haben noch ein paar Tools integriert, die tue ich schon mal herunterladen, das dauert nämlich eine ganze Ecke, das sind 500 Megabit, die lasse ich mal wieder zu laut.
500 MB Tools!
Kein Wunder, dass der Rechner danach langsam ist.
Der ist nach dem runterladen erstmal langsam, dass man ihn wieder optimieren muss, dass er dann wieder genauso schnell ist wie vorher.
Wir schauen erstmal rein in die Registry Tweaks, da ist alles mögliche aus dem alten Tuning Pack plus ein paar Erweiterungen dabei.
Ihr sucht euch raus, was ihr wollt und hakt das an oder hakt das ab und sucht euch aus, was ihr wollt.
Ja, das ist okay, das kann man machen.
Das ist sehr wichtig, ihr lest euch das genau durch, entweder auf Englisch oder auf Deutsch, das heißt international, wir wollen auch ein bisschen unser Reich weiter erhöhen.
Also kann man das Ganze auch auf Englisch vorfinden, falls mir das Deutsche nicht ganz so mächtig ist.
Schaut sich an, geplante Aufgaben, was brauche ich da, was brauche ich da nicht.
Die Bundesstaatprogramme, unsere Spezial Tweaks und dann hake ich da an, was ich möchte.
Selmo, das würde ich nicht machen, das ging darum, wenn du ein Virus hast, da würde ich nicht drüber installieren.
Ich würde die Platte formatieren und neu installieren.
Wenn du drüber installierst, hast du ja noch Sachen übrig von vorher.
Was ist das jetzt?
Internet Explorer, elf Tweaks.
Oh, Internet Explorer, ja.
Das sind alles Einstellungen, die sind mit Sicherheit nicht verkehrt.
Denn Mausbeschleunigungsfix, das war mal früher, wo ich noch CS gespielt habe, war das voll angesagt, dass man den machen muss.
Ich glaube, den braucht man in der neuen Windows Version gar nicht mehr, aber da bin ich mir jetzt nicht so sicher.
Und kann schon auch Make FPS Rain machen.
Was halt, wisst ihr was, in dem GUI halt richtig gut wäre, dass man mal einen Tooltip hat oder eine Hilfebox, was was ist, was was ist.
Was ist das?
Jaxbox 115 Label.
Es ist definitiv ein Windows Forms Ding.
Wenn ich mich nicht mit diesen ganzen Tweaks auseinandersetzen will und keine Ahnung habe, was die da machen, haben wir hier Vorlagen.
In den Vorlagen ist jede Menge Optimierung enthalten.
Entweder die beste Performance, die ultimative Performance, da ist dann auch der Ultimate Performance Mode von Windows mit drin, der gleich mit aktiviert wird.
Und CPU-Parking wird deaktiviert, also die Hardcore-Variante, die viel Strom frisst und vielleicht auch die CPU von Laptops runterklocken könnte und Laptop-Akkus trainen.
Deshalb ist das nur was für Desktop-Rechner und echte Hardcore-Fans.
Natürlich haben wir auch andere Vorlagen erstellt.
What?
Wenn meine CPU was macht, dann ist sie nicht im Stromsparmodus.
Zum Beispiel die Batterielaufzeit, so lange wie möglich auf dem Laptop rauszuzögern oder die beste Privatsphäre einstören.
Das heißt, die wenigsten Telemetriedaten, die an Windows gesendet werden und so weiter, so secure wie möglich.
Oder natürlich Clear Profile.
Ich komme immer noch nicht darauf klar, dass er redet wie mein Zahnarzt.
Dass wir einfach nur Windows entbloten wollen.
In den höheren Profilen wie beste Performance und ultimative Performance ist natürlich die beste Privatsphäre einstellt, schon mit integriert.
Natürlich ist ja auch voll logisch nach diesem GUI.
Es gibt verschiedene Vorlagen.
Es ist natürlich voll logisch, dass die Vorlage, die in der Mitte steht, in der untersten Vorlage natürlich mit drin ist.
Ganz klar.
Ganz logisch.
Performance und ultimative Performance ist natürlich die beste Privatsphäre.
Am besten rein mal UI-Empfehlung.
Wenn das Dinger sind, die quasi mehrere Sachen enthalten, dann sollte man nicht ein Dropdown-Menü machen,
sondern tatsächlich Checkbox und so nach dem Motto, ich möchte Privacy-Settings,
ich möchte Battery-Lifetime und ich möchte Deep-Load-Hegchen machen.
Da kannst du es nämlich auch so machen, dass wenn sich Sachen ausschließen, dass sie nicht miteinander funktionieren.
Was haben die eigentlich davon, so ein Programm zu machen? Verdienen doch nichts dran.
Werbung für sich vielleicht? Ich weiß nicht.
Ich kann doch nicht mal sagen, was es unter der Haube macht, kann sogar sinnvoll sein.
Das kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Schon mit integriert. Ich will natürlich die ultimate Performance, auch wenn das ein Laptop ist, der hält das aus.
Cool und ich apply das Ganze und dann werden hier die Haken dementsprechend gesetzt.
Das ist ganz schick gemacht, dass man danach gucken kann.
Einstellung dazu, aber ich will natürlich noch ein paar Tweets mehr haben.
Also ich hätte gerne Checkbox 117.
Was ist eigentlich ein Telemetrie-Server?
Die Geschichten, wo du zum Beispiel, wenn du aufzeichnest, wie lang ein User im Warenkorb verbringt.
So und das schickst du dann an einen Telemetrie-Server.
Das ist der, der für die Sachen zum Sammeln zuständig ist.
Nee, nee, nee Leute. Checkbox 117 ist besser als Checkbox 115. Das weiß doch jeder.
Weil 117, es gibt hier hinten schon mal neun, das ist 69 und dann passt das.
Blockiere mehr Microsoft-Server, jawoll.
Bam, gibt's eben, Alter. Blockiere mehr Microsoft-Server.
Das ist der TGF-Mausbeschleunigungs-Tool. Das tut automatisch die richtige Skalierung auswählen von eurem Bildschirm und es anwenden. Und dann sag ich, pass auf, hier diesen Haken, ich will die Registry vorher sichern und ich will ein System Wiederherstellungszeitpunkt stellen.
Das ist tatsächlich sehr sinnvoll, ja.
Weil in diesem Tool ist keine Möglichkeit drin, Rollback zu machen. Das heißt, ihr könnt nicht die Haken abhaken und dann Make it rain machen, das geht nicht. Es geht nicht rückgängig. Es gibt keine Möglichkeit das rückgängig zu machen.
Deswegen erstellen wir einen System Wiederherstellungszeitpunkt, den ihr relativ einfach wieder aufrufen könnt.
Was war das gerade für eine Fehlerworte? Da stand irgendwas von, dass man Backup machen soll.
Und wir zeigen euch jetzt auch gleich wie das geht. Dazu geht ihr auf euren Computer, schaut in die Eigenschaften und von den Eigenschaften schaut ihr auf erweiterte Systemeinstellungen.
Und von da könnt ihr rübergehen auf den Computerschutztab und hier ist die System Wiederherstellung.
Die klickt ihr an, nachdem natürlich unser Backup gemacht wurde. Auf weiter und da seht ihr auch schon...
Da hatte er erstmal die Schmerztabletten stehen. Nee, keine Ahnung was das ist.
Oh, das Studio sah hier so hübsch aus. Hier sieht es genauso aus wie bei mir.
Auf weiter und da seht ihr auch schon den System Wiederherstellungszeitpunkt.
RaveMaster, das ist schwierig so Sachen rückgängig machbar zu machen.
Fertig, zack und schon wird das System zurück.
Also mit rückgängig machen haben auch große Automatisierungssysteme Probleme.
Guckt euch zum Beispiel mal Puppet an. Das ist ein Tool, was recht beliebt war und immer noch ist, um Server reproduzierbar aufzubauen.
Selbst die bieten keinen Rollback an. Es ist nicht so einfach Rollbacks zu machen.
Alle Änderungen sind rückgängig gemacht. Das ist natürlich auch wichtig, falls irgendwelche Probleme sich ergeben oder ihr andere Einstellungen ausprobieren wollt.
An leichterem Weg gibt es leider zu diesem Zeitpunkt nicht. Ja, an welchem ich dir recht.
Es ist ziemlich komplex und ziemlich schwierig, weil wir sehr tief eingreifen...
Am besten ist ein Docker Compose File und Ruhe für so Kleinkramen.
Wir greifen ein in die Apps, die vorinstalliert sind und so weiter. Deswegen ist uns das wichtig.
So, wenn das gemacht wurde, seht ihr schon, hier ist der Progress Bar schon durchgelaufen mit den ganzen Programmen.
Yay!
Jetzt haben wir diese ganzen Tweaks und so weiter hier durchgeführt und das ist super toll. Reboot!
Genau, da oben ist ein Knopf. Wer es schon mal erkannt hat, Ninite.
Wer es nicht kennt, Ninite ist ein Download-Client. Dafür gibt es auch eine Homepage.
Da muss man separat drauf gehen und so weiter. Und dann kann man Windows-spezifische Programme, die man sowieso mal gebrauchen kann, runter...
Wie wäre es, wenn man einfach den offiziellen Client dafür verwendet?
Rollen wir mal zurück, der Error in der CMD.
Also ich persönlich bin ja immer noch für Shoko bei systemweite Programme als auch Scoop für User-Programme.
Was, Fehler? Ist entweder falsch geschrieben oder kann ich gefunden werden?
Es gibt halt, da sind da wahrscheinlich auch Tweaks drin, die in der neuesten Windows-Version nicht gehen.
Nein, ich wollte sagen, das ist sogar Absicht. Das führt halt einfach Sachen aus.
Und wenn sie da sind, gehen sie. Und wenn sie nicht da sind, gehen sie nicht.
Mit den ganzen Programmen Make FPS Rain und wir sind durch.
Jetzt haben wir diese ganzen Tweaks und so weiter hier durchgeführt und das ist super toll.
Aber was fehlt uns denn noch? Genau, da oben ist ein Knopf.
Erst mal Reboot!
Wer es nicht kennt, Ninite ist ein Download-Client. Dafür gibt es auch eine Homepage.
Da muss man separat drauf gehen und so weiter.
Und dann kann man Windows-spezifische Programme, die man sowieso mal gebrauchen kann, herunterladen, wie zum Beispiel Chrome oder WinRAR, 7-Zip, CD-Burner-XP.
Ich meine, guckt euch mal an, im Vergleich zu Scoop ist da nichts drin oder im Vergleich zu Shoko, da ist ja nichts drin.
Ich konnte kein Node.js installieren, nichts.
FTP-Reader.
Kein CMDR, nichts.
Alles, was man braucht, wenn man PC neu installiert.
Nee, da ist nichts von dem dabei, was ich brauche.
Und ich kann das jetzt aussuchen. Ich mache das jetzt mal.
Thunderbird ist eigentlich ganz cool, WinRAR braucht man eigentlich immer.
WinRAR.
PC ist auch sehr praktisch.
Vor allem WinRAR.
Ja, das brauche ich jetzt nicht unbedingt.
TeamViewer sollte man haben.
Und man sollte auch Foxit-Reader drauf haben und Pudi brauche ich manchmal.
Und ein Notepad plus plus.
So, dann suche ich mir aus, welche Programme ich habe und dann klicke einfach auf install.
Download wird gestartet und das war es auch schon.
Hier kommt Ninite und installiert das Ganze.
Es ist ein All-in-one-Downloader für alle Programme, die gebraucht werden,
die die meisten Leute brauchen und installiert haben.
Dass man sowas braucht, liegt einfach nur daran,
dass Windows immer noch keinen gescheiten Package-Manager hat.
Die man nicht separat runterladen will und immer auf jede Seite und usw.
Das vereinfacht.
Ja, haben wir uns vor ein paar Tagen angeguckt.
Ach nee, Moment, nicht FreeOffice.
Wir haben uns KingdingsbumsOffice angeguckt vor ein paar Tagen.
Einfach den Download, wir haben Lust, kommen mit Programme.
Dachten wir, es ist eine schöne Integration.
Das macht das Tuning-Pack noch ein kleines bisschen runter,
weil wir dann vom Optimieren bis hin zum Programme-Installieren eigentlich alles abdecken.
Und was noch schöner ist.
Was wollten wir noch erzählen jetzt?
Es sind nicht nur die Ninite-Programme, sondern wir haben auch noch ein kleines Custom-Pack zusammengestellt,
das euch hilft, PTs zu debuggen, mir zu finden, das System zu säubern usw.
Also schauen wir rein.
Wenn wir jetzt auf Werkzeug waren und haben die Tools heruntergeladen,
haben wir das Tuning-Pack einmal geschlossen und wieder geöffnet.
Das ist wichtig, weil die Aktualisierung noch nicht funktioniert.
Kommt aber bald.
Dann seht ihr hier schon ganz viele coole Programme.
Wir haben Programme, die das Temp verzeichnen.
Das haben wir uns gerade.
Oder wir haben Manual-Tools.
ADW-Cleaner, PC-Hunter, Kill-Process.
Leute, die sich sowas herunterladen, die können das meiste von Hand machen.
Also z.B. Temp-Dateien löschen und sowas.
Und Park-Control ist auch mit da.
Oder wir haben z.B.
Park-Control kann wirklich sinnvoll sein.
Erstmal schön die SST defragmentieren.
Ihr könnt direkt aus unserem Tool aufrufen.
Und wieder könnt ihr auch hier ein kleines bisschen...
So.
Und dann geht das Ding durch und schaut, ob wir uns auf dem System sind.
Unser Pack wird nicht als Virus erkannt.
Das sage ich gleich mal vorweg.
Ihr könnt auch Page-Fire-Reset machen.
Oder die Festplatte mit dem Defragler defragmentieren.
Defragler?
Ja, erstmal schön die SST defragen.
Alles mit integriert ist alles mit da.
Das heißt, ihr habt eine All-in-One-Solution für alle PC-Probleme.
Direkt hier mit eingebaut.
Formatierungsprogramme.
Ihr könnt die Downloads durchgehen.
Ihr könnt euer System bereinigen.
Ihr könnt euer System optimieren.
Das erinnere ich hab voll...
Ich hab so voll die Flashbacks zu Zeiten, wo die Leute immer
Tune-Up-Tools und so installiert hat.
Installiert haben.
Warum nicht die SST defragmentieren?
Weil eine SST nicht fragmentiert.
Du musst den SST nicht defragmentieren.
Defragmentieren...
Macht ihr auf einer Magnetfestplatte
das quasi zusammenhängende
Daten hintereinander stehen.
Allerdings auf der SST
hast du ja keinen Schreiblesekopf,
der da rum... oder eine Scheibe,
die rumfährt unten.
Du hast einen Controller, die wissen, wo die Daten liegen
und gut ist. Du musst eine SST nicht
defragmentieren. Das macht es eher
schlimmer.
Nach euren Vorstellungen
und Wünschen. Und wir geben euch die Tools dazu.
Es werden immer wieder neue Tools hinzugefügt
von uns. Und immer wieder neue Tools...
Da bin ich ja froh, dass da immer mehr dazu kommt.
Okay.
Noch nicht.
Und jetzt gibt es noch das zweiteilige Messerset.
Tweaks und Optionen, die werdet
ihr hier bald finden. Und die werden von uns hinzugefügt.
Ah, Label 515.
Das kommt aber mit dem nächsten Update.
Und zwar könnt ihr euer eigenes Profil erstellen.
Das heißt, ihr wählt euer Haken an.
Okay, ja, nice. Coverbar.
Und wenn das irgendwie mal wieder nicht
funktioniert... Wobei, als eigenes Profil
speichern bringt doch überhaupt nichts. Weil ich mache ja
dann Systemwiederherstellungspunkt.
Und dann ist ja das eigene Profil weg.
Weil ich kann das nicht
rollbacken.
...
Die Leute freuen sich, die sind da richtig armer, ausrasten.
Das ist ein Fake-Kommentar oder was?
WTF?
Danke, jetzt kann ich Videos in mit 4K aufnehmen und spiele mit bester Qualität.
Nichts davon hat dafür gesorgt, dass der auf einmal Videos in 4K aufnehmen kann.
Er hatte Minilecks beim...
What the...
Was machen die Leute mit ihren Rechnern?
What the... Was machen die Leute mit ihren Rechnern?
Ja...
Ja, er hat es erstellt.
Ok, ich hab...
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Ok, die feiern das ja ultra, die Leute.
Oh, die feiern das ja ultra, die Leute.
Normies!
Ok...
Ok, wir gucken mal schnell in den Sourcecode rein.
Wo ist das source code?
Templates?
PowerShell?
Nee, nee, nee, nee.
Gui, gui, gui.
Das ist eine PowerShell Gui?
WTF?
Sowas geht, ja klar geht sowas.
Du kannst den PowerShell komplett auf alle.NET Klassen...
Das ist eine PowerShell...
Das hab ich ja noch nie gesehen.
Also ich weiß, dass es geht, weil du kannst auf alle.NET Sachen...
Der macht Windows Forms in PowerShell.
Ok, also zumindest...
Da muss ich echt...
Da muss ich echt meinen Hut ziehen vor der Kreativität, ja?
Du kannst auch PtWPF in PowerShell... Klar, du kannst in PowerShell jegliche.NET Klassen verwenden.
Ach du Scheiße.
Der komplette Windows Forms Anwendung in PowerShell.
Globale Variablen, soweit das Auge reicht.
Wie viele Zeilen hatten das Ganze?
Beide komplett?
Das komplette?
Erinnert euch... Wir haben doch an 1500...
Wir haben doch an Weihnachten ein bisschen an meiner Videokamera Streaming Überwachungssoftware programmiert.
Die ursprüngliche Version aus Go und C hatte wie viel?
400 Zeilen? 500 Zeilen mit HTML Frontend?
Also Go Source Code, C Source Code und HTML Frontend hatte 500 Zeilen?
Die komplette Anwendung hatte 500 Zeilen?
Ich meine, es ist jetzt auch nicht der Wahnsinns in Ultra Best Ever oder so, aber...
Okay, was auch immer.
Vor allem in PowerShell, das kann ja keiner processen im Kopf, Alter.
Hat man in PowerShell überhaupt Autocomplete für sowas?
Die Source Hilfe, in welcher Sprache ist das?
Hat man Autocomplete überhaupt in PowerShell?
Wenn man sowas macht...
Button 43, also damit kann ich mich identifizieren.
Ihr kennt das ja noch aus den alten Streams.
Ich bin ja auch nicht der Beste, was Variabelbenamung angeht, ja.
Guckt ihr mal an, der den Browser zum Laggen bringt, okay.
Ja gut, das ist halt die Scheiße, dass es so unendlich viele Zahlen gibt.
Es gibt halt so viele Zahlen.
Und wenn man jegliche Zahl Hardcoden will, ist das halt problematisch.
Ja, Scheiße, dass es so viele Zahlen gibt, ja.
Wobei ich das echt...
Das ist aber ein Gebate, oder?
Das ist ein Gebate.
Okay, ich muss jetzt...
Ich muss ihr leider gestehen.
Die Gui, source technisch, ist genauso wir, wie es aussieht.
Und es bestätigt voll den Eindruck, den ich von diesem Tool hatte.
Denn Windows forms Gui in PowerShell.
Ich finde das schon, ich finde das schon so abgedreht, dass ich sagen würde, also für so
Es ist kreativ, ja
Ach so was, checkbox 100, checkbox
Checkbox 150, gibt's gar nicht
Das ist nicht die letzte Version, Leute
Das ist nicht die letzte Version, Label
Äh Label, 33, ne? Comic, Sans
117, 117 gibt's auch nicht
Image, 33, das ist doch nicht euer Ernst, ey, was ist denn das, Alter?
Das ist, was ist das? Von PP Gas für PP Gas oder was?
Was, ich bin nicht auf Master? Doch, ich bin auf Master, ist doch gut
Wo soll denn das sonst gefixt werden, wenn nicht auf Master?
Die machen alles nur, der macht doch keine Dev-Branche, was meinst du dann?
Ah, Moment, da gibt's nen Designer, es gibt nen Designer?
Wie, wie macht man das?
Ich hab legit keine Ahnung, mit welchem Tool ich ein PowerShell GUI designen kann
Ist da was? poshgui.com?
ach
Was, echt cool, was, poshgui?
Aha
Hier, es ist, Alter, es ist ein Windows-Forms-Editor für PowerShell im Browser
So was gibt es?
Krasser Scheiß, also man, ich bin, ihr merkt, ich bin sprachlos
Choose my name, nein, du kannst DLL import theoretisch, auch in PowerShell machen, oder?
Okay, ich nehme das zurück, ich hab jetzt ne Ahnung, ich weiß jetzt, dass es sowas gibt, aber nochmal eine andere Frage
Warum, warum, also wenn man die Auswahl hat, ich mein, es ist unter der Haube ein stinknormales.net-Programm
Für Windows, wenn ich die Auswahl habe, mir kostenlos beispielsweise ein Visual Studio runterzuladen und ein minimales C-Sharp.net-Programm zu basteln
Versus ein ewig langes PowerShell-Skript mit nem Browser-UI-Editor, warum mach ich das?
Sachen gibt es, Sachen gibt es, also krasser Scheiß, krasser Scheiß, Alter, also pff
Also ich bin, ihr merkt, ich bin komplett sprachlos, Alter, also, komplett
Update German
Eins muss man, muss man ihm lassen, er hat das Ding zumindest übersetzungsfähig designt, irgendwie, ein bisschen, ja, also
Krasser, also pff, das hätte ich nicht gedacht, dass wir sowas heute nochmal sehen, ne
Achso, Checkbox 117 wollte ich grad nachgucken, okay
Checkbox 117, Null, Checkbox, Tab, hier, Checkbox
Checkbox, what, Moment, die Ausrichtung, die Ausrichtung der Checkbox ist, ist Hard-Coded
Mit Pixel-Angaben, ich mein, es ist Windows Forms, in Windows Forms war vieles nicht möglich, aber, aber man konnte in Windows Forms auch Anchor und so benutzen, dass es gleich bleibt, ja, also, das
Das ist so apathisch, ja, das stimmt schon, ich glaube, ich habe noch nie, jetzt, ungelogen, ich glaube, ich hab noch nie
Einen Hard-Coded Windows, also so einen Hard-Coded Windows Forms-Guih gesehen
Ja, ja, das hat er natürlich selbst gemacht, das macht der Editor, aber trotzdem, Alter, man hätte den Editor ja mal eingestellt, dass man, dass man einen Anchor setzen will an die rechte Seite, oder so
Schauen wir mal in das Programm, ja, gut, das ist, das ist veraucht, ne, hier, NITesigner, ne, die machen
Wo könnten, wo könnten das drinstehen? Chrome, Chrome, ja, Chrome, Textbox 1, Textbox 1 Click Event, wo ist das Textbox 1 Click Event?
Textbox 1 Click, wo ist Textbox 1 Click? Textbox 1 Click, Link, Nite.com, Link
Link, Link gleich, Link plus minus Chrome
Fuck, man kommt da ernsthaft auf, wow
Na, Nite ist okay, das gibt schon ne Weile, aha, ja gut, so baut er das zusammen
So, und wo wird gedownloaded? Okay, jetzt, jetzt check ich's nicht mehr
Es, da, da kommt, da kommt ne Url raus, da kommt ne Url raus und am Ende hängt der Slash, add x an, also da kommt dann, da kommt dann
Unten ist ein, ah, ja, aber trotzdem, wie funktioniert das? Okay, das ist okay, da kommt dann so ne Url raus hier
Da kommt dann das da, minus, minus Chrome, Slash, sowas, hä, was, was soll denn das für ne Url sein?
Nein, das ist ne Url, so, und, und, und dann downloadet er das? Hä?
Nee, der hängt hier an dem Link noch hinten was an, also, okay, ah, okay, das ist im Prinzip das gleiche wie vorher, man hätte es sich auch sparen können, ah, verstehe, verstehe, verstehe
Okay, im Prinzip lädt er Chrome runter, beziehungsweise Installer, in den, in den, nein, nicht, nicht, was auch immer, Installer lädt er runter für Chrome
Und dann macht er install Excel, okay, also im Prinzip, also da werden keine Hashtummen oder sowas überprüft, also da könnte, da könnte alles runterladen, ja
Wollen wir mal ein GitHub-Issue aufmachen, beim Download Hashtummen überprüfen oder so?
So, und was macht, was ist install Excel? Wo ist denn install Excel überhaupt?
Install Excel, remove install Excel, ach so, ah, der W gettet das und nennt es install Excel, und danach führt der install Excel aus, und danach löscht das wieder, okay, also, ja, gut, naja, naja, was willst du sonst groß machen?
Also das ist, es ist ein bisschen umständlich, ja, aber im Prinzip ist das, wie willst du sonst großartig anders machen? Du downloadest das, startest das und löscht es wieder
Sie könnten Scoop bundeln und das machen lassen, dann werden zumindest Hashtummen berechnet, ja
Aber Ejax, du hast recht, da wirst du bekloppt, wenn ihr die Comments durchliest, ja, ja gut, kann man so machen, kann man so machen, ja
Kann man so machen, sonderlich sicher ist das ganze natürlich nicht, muss man, muss man sagen, ähm, kann man machen, muss man aber nicht
Okay, wer auch immer diesen Link gepostet hat, nice, jetzt hatten wir nochmal schöne Stunde was zu tun
Das Problem ist, dass das Tuning Pack das Internet Explorer Modul aus dem.NET Framework benutzt, um die neueste Version abzurufen, das ist so
Aha, Internet Explorer in 2020
Ich bin auch gerade nicht verwirrt Leute, also jetzt habt ihr, das hättet ihr mir nicht zeigen dürfen
Mir war bisher nicht klar, dass es einen PowerShell UI Designer gibt und dass es tatsächlich Leute gibt, die PowerShell Windows Forms UIs sein
Auf, auf das Video, nein, ich, ich, ich reakte doch nicht auf React, äh, wozu, wozu soll ich auf mein Reaction, Reaction Video reacten
Äh, ETF, so Leute, ich muss morgen arbeiten gehen, ich hab's, ich, Moment, ich guck's mir an
Das ist mein altes Intro
Das ist mein altes Video, du hast mein Intro aus meinem Video rausgeschnitten
Ja, vielleicht mach ich in das nächste Video wieder das Intro rein
Könntest du einem Unwissen den Unterschied zwischen PowerShell und Batch erklären? Ja, Batch ist uralt und Crap und PowerShell ist neu und für Automatisierung gut, aber als interaktive Shell Crap
Was? Das letzte Mal, als ich dich danach gefragt habe, hast du gesagt, mach das Intro rein, wenn 25 Subs gifte
Was? Habe ich das gemacht? Aber du hast keine 25 Subs gegiftet
Ja, da kann ich, da kann ich nichts, ok Leute, ich muss ins Bett, ich bin schon ganz schön spät
Wir sehen uns die Tage morgen, mal gucken, bis dann, macht's gut, CU